on merger materials referencing hp2
half of the university and Community
College system I do have
another date which I've set up for the
subcommittee and it should be in the
calendar
um we're meeting a course this Friday
I've mentioned that previously and the
following Friday but we also will be
meeting on the 17th which is the
Wednesday at 10 o'clock and at that
meeting I have
um folks coming in from for helping us
out they're coming from the University
system as well as the community college
system uh Susan jeward who is the
chancellor and
um I have on the other side uh Ron
Rogers coming in and Don Burks now Susan
George and Don Burke are both
practitioners very involved with
actually of Interest presidents of
various uh policies at their level and
also instruction involved with that and
that's where our primary focus is on
policy and academic policy and of course
the policy associated with the finance
as well but they will be coming in on
Wednesday so we have to have the final
brief report done by Society uh two
Fridays from now this Friday and the
next Friday then we have to be done so
we have basically three
um
dating uh the last Friday I have a
Barbara brittenham she is from neshi and
very familiar in fact is the guru
kineshi for accreditation we're very
fortunate to have her she's now today
over in the United Kingdom working with
several colleges up there but she will
be back here to work with us and provide
some insight in terms of how that is
impacted when organizational structure
is changed so with that I'm going to go
into the Chairman's script for today's
meeting and we do have a number of
executive sessions so we need to get uh
going here
as chair of the House Education
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor
has a result of covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with household 67 the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referring to the education committee
this is also primarily today and is an
executive committee for members of the
committee uh dealing with bills that
have been referred to the education
committee please note that there is no
fit and executive session on pending
legislation may be held even Beyond
those executive sessions schedules
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff happy building
communication temporaneously during this
meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary to access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice where this meeting implies
with house rules and RSA 91-8 anyone who
has a problem with accessing the meeting
should call
in the event the public assigned will
access the meeting the meeting will be
re-adjourned and rescheduled
I want to introduce a staff that are on
the meeting assisting us today our
researcher Jennifer floor and please
note that all votes that are taken
during this meeting shall be done by a
roll call let's start the meeting by
taking a roll call attendance when each
member state would win each member
states their presence please also State
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required under the rational law
uh Madam Clerk yes uh representative
cordelli here in the Green Room
representative bone here in the
committee room representative Aller here
in the committee room representative
here in the committee room
representative Moffett here in the
committee room
representative Andrus here home alone in
Salisbury
representative Ford
good morning
representative land
um home in Dairy with my family in the
house in and out of this room today
representative
representative Miler here in Kentucky
New Hampshire alone
representative Shaw here in the
committee room Senator Cornell you're in
Manchester
representative Tanner uh here in Georges
Mills Sunapee uh with my rescue dog
Raven who may bark
representative Ellison
here I'm
home in Concord
representative Mullen dialing in alone
in balmy Bedford
oh
representative lay
I am at my office in Bow New Hampshire
and I am alone
representative woodcock
here in Center Conway New Hampshire my
wife will be in and out and my dog will
surely be barking
representative Ladd I am here in the LOB
okay so we're going to be working
through this talk we have today on our
executive session uh I'm going to start
with the first bill HP 278 uh but I want
all to know that I I may jump around on
certain bills uh on the docket not
necessarily go in any specific order
so with that uh 278 and I'd look for a
motion from represent cordelli thank you
Jeremy
I'd like to uh
podcast
um House Bill 278 relative to the new
representative I'll second that thank
you very much so we have a motion on the
table which is ought to pass made by
representative cordelli and second by
representative Moffett represent
cordelli do uh
how many Pearls of Wisdom
[Music]
I think that
testimony
child
this year
throughout the Lost Space by charts
are 3.6 million dollars
they get no additional funding for use
for yeast or mental of space
and I think that this bill provides an
still in space
it's really using
space that has been built for public
education and charter schools are
important schools so I think it's
of legislation thank you thank you very
much Mr chair Mr chair
I I'm having a hard time here uh
representative cordelli it's very um
and not very clear and I don't know if
it's my age or just that that's what's
happening oh it's the microphone if he
can use a microphone that would be great
thank you everything was inaudible Mr
chair
listen now see if that's any better is
this any better yes yes yes thank you
uh the only thing I was saying Mr
chairman is that uh one of the concerns
about this was what if a Walmart or some
entity he had a lot of money he wanted
to make the first offer and the answer
to that simply is that uh the charter
school would have a chance to nasty
offer if they put not in the district
could sell to the uh whoever bought for
them the most money so the right first
represent Allison
uh thank you Mr chair uh I have uh two
school districts in my legislative
district Concord and Merrimack Valley
and in the past few years we've gone
through this whole issue of schools
which become available because of new
construction and I I think it's useful
for the committee just to hear where
four of these went uh one of them uh one
of the elementary schools became a
community center with rooms for senior
citizens uh the branch library uh an
auditorium another one of the schools
was sold to a private organization the
Communications Group which then put that
particular building back on the tax
rolls and contributed money to the
school system a third one was the smalls
Elementary School which became the
school's central office and the fourth
one which is in Penacook became the CSI
charter school which is a
competency-based uh charter school that
serves students not only from the
Merrimack Valley District book for
surrounding districts uh this bill with
its right of first refusal
uh would could cause issues with any
school district or municipality that it
buildings that weren't uh weren't uh
needed anymore I I guess I would raise
the issue for instance uh in any one of
the four examples that I use to you uh
let's assume uh Charter School from
Laconia wanted to open a branch in
Concord uh they could have filed on any
one of these four cases
the writer first refusal and
theoretically kept the city of Concord
or pentacook from using their buildings
in a way that they saw fit I see this
bill is is the exact opposite of local
control we talk a lot in this committee
about local control and how important
that is uh
under this bill we would be having the
state tell local municipalities how to
utilize their own property that is the
exact opposite of local control uh and I
will be voting against the motion thank
you Mr chairman thank you for further
discussion representative
uh yeah thank you Mr chairman do we have
any
um data on problems with this uh in
school districts for charter schools
have sought uh to use uh unused space
hey that question can you open up yeah
just to anyone I I don't have an answer
that's why I'm asking the question
is there anybody that might have
something that's I see a representative
it's not like it's your hand and stuff
yes I have been told that a charter
school in Manchester has
um repeatedly tried to leave space from
uh Manchester and Manchester currently
has four schools that are supposed to be
closed and they have been trying for
thank you Manchester doesn't have any
schools that are close
we need to ask uh sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry
I do have something to add to the
discussion no it's just that there are
no schools in Manchester that are closed
and empty at this time
so I I don't know where that information
is representative Shaw
um yes I agree with uh representative
Cornell
um with all the respect uh I think there
is a a charter school that might be
interested in one of the schools that is
about to be closed if it gets closed it
hasn't been finalized yet uh but
um I do not believe that there has ever
been an issue in Manchester that I know
of and sitting on the
um Alderman board uh that would come
before us and I'm chairman of lands of
buildings and I have never heard of that
issue uh arising in Manchester and I
think that um I agree with the
representative Ellison uh I think they
have a fair right to
um to apply uh for these schools and
they've been granted there is at least
one in Manchester that's in a
former school facility it's I mean a
former facility it's not a school but
it's a a an unused City facility so I I
really don't think that I I agree that
that it should be the local districts
that
um will uh identify uh what they're
going to do with these buildings and and
it's usually a cordial uh reception for
uh Charter Schools when they're looking
for a place thank you thank you very
much representative
absently
thank you Mr chairman
um I did have a couple of questions yet
that I think were not answered in the
hearing
um so on line 9 page one
um School of board approved plan shall
include direct student academic
instruction that was never really
defined what that would mean and I
recall posing the question if the school
district owns an SAU building which is a
school-owned bill a district-owned
building but there is no instruction
engaging occurring there is that subject
to this
um I also recall that I believe it was
Carl Ladd at one point pointed out on
page two lines 22 24
during the terms of Elise chartered
Public Schools shall be responsible for
direct expenses
Etc but the question was if the district
has taken out a bond for example to
improve the HVAC system uh does the
charter school bear any portion of that
cost once um once it is uh in in the
inside of the building uh so you know
there are questions here that still
remain
it seems to me that we are mandating
something which districts can already do
and have done there has been no evidence
presented here today or in the prior
hearing
of actual problems with the current
system as it operates and this
contradicts uh the Mantra that we hear
of local control so for all of those
reasons uh I certainly will oppose this
Bill thank you
representative uh like us you have
um
yes I I wasn't saying that there were
schools currently open in Manchester I
had said that there were four that we
were talking about
but the person who told me that there
was an issue was actually somebody
somebody Associated I don't remember
whether he said he was on the board or
whatever of a charter school and because
Manchester had some space they had been
he said over the last few years trying
to lease some space in those classrooms
and so anyway just wanted to make clear
what I was trying to say
thank you Bob representative Ellison did
you have your hand up again oh I'm sorry
thank you Mr chairman hey representative
thank you very much Mr chair I wanted to
go back to the um the um you know
notwithstanding the the fact that
Manchester hasn't hasn't um closed any
of their school buildings but I wanted
to go back to representative Lee kisses
hypothetical so I'm just wondering how
how 278 should should the school
district not wish to um to sell a school
building how 278 would address the
um
my understanding is that I mean if they
don't want to sell the building they
don't want to sell the building but my
understanding is that there were for the
recommendation of the latest study was
that there would be four buildings that
they should be closing and that would
give and and that would give the
opportunity for um
that Charter School
to get that space But I was only
saying anything because somebody said
have there been problems in the past so
that's what
I'm sorry but but looking at page one
line 17 through 20. it's only if the
school district school district school
board extends an offer for a purchase or
lease to um to a party other than the
other than the chartered school so if
they're not interested in
selling or leasing the space I don't
think 278 compels the school board to um
to necessarily uh sell or lease the
space to anybody
including a chartered school
I'm just wondering how this fixed the
problem that you're talking about
so I didn't think they were just going
to leave the building after
empty further further comments
representative
thank you um I was just I had a question
too and maybe representative Shaw since
she deals with this a lot
um I was surprised in this bill how it
how it um
not only took away local control to to
the extent of uh who got the building or
who got first refusal on the building
but also how it delineated uh parts of
the lease and um I'm just wondering if
that's a common practice when
public buildings are uh leased or sold
that
um
something like this in law says what
they have to do as far as the lease is
concerned
representative
the microphone please microphone please
I can't hear you again
um
that it says in the right of first
refusalem
it shall be the option offering School
District whether to sell at least the
properties under consideration at fair
market value for a term to be agreed
upon by Apartments so I I differ as to
whether there is local control in this
legislation or not
what what lines were you referring to
engage two uh the middle of the page
I'm 13 14 15. Mr chair
I was um uh speaking to the you know the
the different
um areas in this bill and I I don't have
a copy with numbers on it so
um but uh section four you know where
where it actually talks about the lease
itself and then again
in section six
um
uh five and six where it's talking about
different things that have to occur
within the lease if it if uh the charter
school does lease the building and I'm
just wondering I I have no idea I'm a
former teacher so I didn't get involved
in this so I'm just wondering if that's
common practice to have those kinds of
pick that question or
well well sure I mean I don't think this
is exactly what what representative
Tanner was talking about but but you
know I think rights of first refusal are
you know commonly
um you know attractive Provisions when
you've already got a lease agreement so
that if the if the landlord I'm talking
about a commercial lease when the If a
landlord wants to sell the business or
the bill I'm sorry the building that
that the the the the the the
um uh the company that's leasing the
space has a um has a right of first
refusal so that if they wanted to remain
there they'd they'd have some some
assurances of that you know aside from
that
um the value of a right of first refusal
and I'm not sure we heard from any
Realtors on this but the value of a
writer first refuse refusal does not
accrue to the building owner in fact it
detracts from the value of the property
because it makes it um it makes it less
I don't know less interesting for for a
third party to um to want to want to
negotiate so given the fact that you
know these are political subdivisions
who we represent implementing a law like
this really only subtracts value from
from our constituents and from our
school from school districts who our
constituents have invested uh tax money
in so I
um you know under any case they'd
certainly have a um you know uh uh
there'd be an opportunity if if a school
building was being put on the market for
a chartered public school to uh to put
an offer in I don't think they need to
write a refer first refusal to do that
which is which is just going to take
away value from our taxpayers
thank you very much representative
um thank you Mr chair for for letting me
speak uh there's also the issue um
representative luno that sometimes
I apologize for the commentary
um if the if the property is not put on
the market and there's a private
agreement to negotiate it then that
would eliminate the ability for a
chartered school or or um to make an
offer on the property so we need to look
at that transparency as well if the if
the towns might be making a private
private agreement I'm not sure that's
that's allowed under New Hampshire law
but I think that's a good good question
to look into
my understanding school boards have to
do things in public at least for my 12
years on the board we did
um we used to talk to Dairy then well
well then there their problem
hey representative
yes I and I'm not sure I want to get
back to Manchester and I'm not sure if
this is right and representative Shaw
would know I think more than I do but I
think if the school district doesn't use
the school building the district does
not have ownership of the building it
refer reverts back to the city of
Manchester
um I think Manchester
Municipal owns the buildings so once
they become empty and the school
district's not using them anymore it's
up to the city of Manchester what to do
with them am I is that wrong you're
correct
so so this wouldn't apply to Manchester
at all because school district would
have no say over what happens to the
buildings
right
further further comments
yes representative
a note on
that I wrote in here that there was an
amendment coming to deal with a
miswording
and
um
we're talking we just had an otpa motion
and not a I mean an OTP not
otpa and I'm wondering about the
which we didn't have it was supposed to
be coming and it was supposed to deal
with um
second page line 12 and shall not be
subject to RSA 91a and that kind of
it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't the right
wording
I do have that note on mine I made also
only I had page two line 11.
uh but it's the same area you're talking
about well yeah it was it was the end of
I I've not seen that
no
further discussion
representative uh
thank you Mr chairman uh just a general
question following up on on
representative Cornell's comment uh
granted this if approved this would be a
Statewide uh legislative action uh has
there any research or background effort
been put in to see how many other cities
and towns would be in the same situation
as Manchester and that this law would
eign
right
yeah
or anyone I mean it doesn't matter I
just asked that question
and nobody has volunteered I'm I'm here
if someone needs to speak with me
good
ask your question uh representative
thank you Mr chair uh representative
Hill thank you for taking the question
um it came up that Manchester is one of
the communities in the state that this
bill would not uh be relevant to because
they have their own uh requirements that
school buildings go back to the
municipality and my question was has
there any been any effort to do any
research at all to check how many other
cities are talents and municipalities in
the state would be in the same situation
with this wall and not be applicable
uh thank you for your question
um the only thing I can tell you is uh
this bill was heard in the Senate uh
not last term I think the term before
and
um and Senator Waters asked about
Manchester and
um and the represent and the senator
from Manchester
um at the time
uh said that that would that was
something that they were looking into
with their legal department
um but it was not no answer ever came
back uh from anyone and and to my
knowledge no one has ever gone and
looked at other
um cities or towns uh or uh and ask that
same question whether there is a
provision in their in their rules if it
doesn't apply it obviously wouldn't
apply that's that's the only answer I
can give you I'm sorry
follow up Mr chair yes
um just representative Hill or because
representative ladder was a co-sponsor
was is there was there any questions to
the mass uh the New Hampshire Municipal
thank you for your question they did not
testify and um and I'm not sure
um
if if they've ever even commented on
this bill
no I meant since you spotted it did you
ever make an effort to ask them
um
boy I don't recall
I I talked to them so many times I don't
recall whether I'm sorry whether they
had commented on this or or whether they
were asked about this no idea
thank you thank you Mr chair
thank you very much
so we do have
we do have a motion at uh on the table
right now it's not to pass
uh is there any further discussion
not seeing it um
to pass on HP 278
representative fall yes
representative Allard yes
representative yes representative
Moffett
yes
representative Hobson
yes representative Andrus yes
representative Ford
yes
representative land
representative yes
representative Myler
no
Representative luno no
representative Shaw no representative
Cornell oh
representative Tanner no
representative Allison oh representative
Mullen no
representative lay
no
is that a woodcock no
five or nine voters eleven to nine uh
ought to pass
uh I'd like to remind people that are
making
um you know reports here that we need to
have these committee reports in as soon
as possible will there be a Minority
Report representative yes uh
representative Cornell will present that
report
okay thank you
and representative Cordell you have the
thank you very much
moving on to the next bill I'm jumping
over 255 and going to HB 140. this is a
bill relative to the private rights of
and I'd like to call upon represent Leon
for a motion please
um thank you Mr chair I would like to
move ought to pass on House Bill 140
relative to right to private action
and representative second or a second so
the motion has been made on 140 pass
made by repson Leon and second by
represent leica's reps on land you have
uh uh any comments
um yes I do thank you Mr chair
right now willing is an issue that's
taken seriously in our schools however
there are occasions where parents are
not appropriately notified or it is not
appropriately managed
by having a right of private action this
gives further encouragement for the
schools to handle these issues
appropriately and it gives them a good a
strong motivation to make sure that
parents are well communicated with this
is something that can have the lives of
our children at risk if they are not do
not have bullying appropriately
addressed and I believe that this is
something that will provide protection
to our students through this threat of
potential legal action and I know
through a personal experience that
lawyers are unlikely to take a case if
they do not believe that the content is
strong so I do not expect that there
would be any misuse of this because it's
a high burden of proof however there are
occasions where this is sorely needed
and children have died because of the
lack of transparency on bullying thank
you thank you very much represent Leon
reps and like us do you have any
comments making the second actually I
think she didn't wonderful job so you're
passing thank you very much uh comments
from the committee
rep sound Bruno thank you very much Mr
chair
um I was just wondering if the language
in this bill particularly on page five
when it refers to school district to
chartered Public Schools is Broad enough
to apply to any approved school and I
was wondering if maybe
um I see we've got Marissa Chase here
that she might be able to comment on um
on the uh the the the
um a bit I guess availability as it as
it relates to uh these sorts of uh right
well I've got I've got the four week old
fear right now how many other people
have communications first or discussion
points uh if we're going to have a
technician offer some input maybe we
ought to have all that you know put out
earlier this week from a parent whose
daughter was in the hospital after a
suicide attempt
the parent relayed the message that she
had been spent more than a year fighting
to have her daughter protected from her
abusers but recently one of the bullies
had
um as the parents hit it up their game
and the daughter had become overwhelmed
and depressed and uh this ended with a
suicide attempt and the daughter is in
the hospital
um
it's it's time to do something
um it is incumbent on the legislature we
are charged
um in the statute with protecting
students from bullying and cyber
bullying it is our job to do this and
it's time we pass this and give some uh
recourse to parents in these situations
Mr chair s
yes I'd like to just clarify something
here
the current law which this repeals and
replaces
says that the private right of action is
not permitted
so parents or others cannot take action
against the school no matter what they
do in this situation
thank you Mr chair
um I have a couple of points one is that
I don't feel that we ever adequately uh
uh addressed the definition of the word
aggrieved and how that could be applied
to
identifying behaviors that were
causing concern or distress within the
school district and uh the second point
that I would like to make is that
um I certainly as a school counselor
dealt with a tremendous number of uh
parent concerns
some of them uh including bullying
concerns
what I'm trying to figure out is
how the legal action of uh family a
is going to directly impact or change
the behavior of a group of let's say
hypothetically seventh grade boys in the
cafeteria that are somehow or another
bullying verbally a kid at a table I I
would like to suggest that perhaps
funding would be better spent rather
than in litigation that it would be
better spent putting Personnel into our
schools that could actually provide
direct support and instruction in
anti-bullying because I just don't see
how a law case in Pembroke is going to
change the behavior of a school child in
Temple
thank you thank you very much
[Music]
represent Leon
thank you very much this this private
right of action goes to the schools and
those who are charged with protecting
our students and our children this is
when they the few times but they do
happen when they drop the ball and they
do not appropriately find alternatives
for these students whether that is
something where they can have
um have an education outside of the
school to get away from their bullies or
addressing the bullying and the bullying
that is happening in the schools the
assaults that are happening in the
schools and the students are sometimes
not protected it is rare that we have
these cases where students are
hospitalized either from their injuries
or from suicide attempts but it happens
this is something that is upon the
administrators it is upon those who work
in the schools who should be protecting
our students and it is for those times
when they fail to do so that is why we
need this and we need to allow the right
of private action rather than prohibit
it which is currently in that law
thank you
um we do have a technical support
available I'm not going to open this up
to another hearing seeing that that
we've already gone through that stage
but if there are specific questions that
have to be asked you're welcome to do so
are we do we have somebody promoted here
now uh
representative can you hear me specific
questions for Marissa first
so Mr chair
I think I'd put one out there
go ahead thanks thanks very much Rick so
uh so thank you very much Miss Chase for
joining us this morning
um uh the question of that I was uh that
I'd like to pose is with respect to the
I guess the scope of the um the
defendants in such a um write a private
action and on line five it talks about
school district or chartered Public
Schools but I know there's there's been
substantial work in this committee
to um to broaden the uh the scope of um
of of schools to uh I think we're seeing
in other bills the use of any approved
school and I was wondering if um if you
know how how that would be looked at
hi can you hear me
okay great sorry my dog is barking in
the background so I apologize a few
times in ahead of me
um thank you very much for the question
representative luno I am not an expert
in
um how how
education law would apply I would just
note that in the statute currently RSA
193 F colon 9 private right of action
not permitted this took effect in 2010
um the language says nothing in this
chapter cell supersede or replace
existing rights or remedies under any
other general or special law including
some of the law nor shall this chapter
create a private right of action for
enforcement of this chapter against
here we go any school district or a
chartered public school or the state so
that language is actually directly from
the statute as it currently exists
right so follow up on that yes
so so if a bullying event was was to
take place at an approved
um School under a tuition program
um uh whether that's a non-sectarian
school or sectarian school or or whatnot
would um uh would would the parents have
uh have a um a tort right or a write a
private action to uh to to take against
um representative I appreciate the
question I am not sure I cannot give a
definitive answer I will just say that
you know the statue currently says
against any school district or chartered
public school or the state
um I I truly don't know I'm happy to do
some more research and get back to you
okay thank you very thank you very much
Miss Chase
are there further questions for Miss
Chase
um yes I as you read that um
193 F uh colon nine it says uh nothing
in this chapter shall supersede or
replace existing rights or remedies
blah blah blah
um once that's repealed does that mean
that the private right of action does in
fact supersede and replace the existing
you know it thank you representative
Tanner it would not
um it would just
I'm sorry this statue I just want to
make an another point and I think going
back to representative Mullen and I I
hope this will answer your question
representative Tanner
um representative Mullen had um
mentioned that these
um oh hold on I'm getting my notes
confused I apologize
um
let me find where the question was just
said
um
it is a high burden and I will note that
the
the statue only went to effect in 2010
prior to 2010 there was not the sort of
blanket immunity that barred these
actions and we we haven't heard
testimony I haven't heard testimony and
I'm not aware of any you know floodgates
of litigation that were happening before
the enactment of the statute
um
you know I I will say that the statute
is a high burden I think to
representative Leon's point that you
know you have to have documented
evidence you have to have an actual
injury
someone can't just make an accusation
and then you know go to court with a
blank check which is not how the system
works I think there has to be repeated
documented
um
actions that show a
injury that the agreed that's what I was
trying to get to representative Mullen
mentioned aggrieved versus injury I
believe and aggrieved in injury is
essentially the same so any plaintiff
would have to show they have an injury
they would have to prove that they got
the injury
by growth negligence on behalf of the
defendant that they caused that by
repeated you know documented
actions and that that entity had a duty
of care to the plaintiff that caused the
injury these are very high burdens
lawyers as I said in my email last night
lawyers work on contingency fee they
front the cost of litigation up front
there's not a financial incentive to
take a case like this where there would
be you know frankly such little recovery
it's only in the most egregious of cases
where a student is is harmed to an
extent that anybody even wants to call a
lawyer
thank you very much Miss cheese
are there further technical questions of
immersive Chase yes representative thank
you Mr chair uh Ms Chase thank you for
taking my question as I read the
proposed legislation uh and I'm looking
at line four specifically where it talks
about any provision of this chapter I'm
assuming that chapter means 93 F not
just that subsection nine is that
correct
foreign let me pull up where you are
looking so I can get on the same page
of this chapter so this chapter is 193 F
colon nine yes so is is it is the I
guess my question then attorney Jay says
is it 193 F or is it 193 specifically
just F9
specifically F9 representative okay and
I just want to make clear I'm not an
attorney I just represent them I just I
just want to make clear I'm happy to
have an attorney hop on the call if you
have further legal technical questions
but I I just don't want to mislead any
members of the community that I have
some technical legal expertise that
that's my error but because my
understanding that when it said chapter
it meant that any violation of 93 F
being the chapter would impact this and
a suit can be brought forward not just
93 uh F9 and I thought that that opens
up the whole Board of issues
thank you hey did anybody do we have any
lawyers on the committee I'm not sure
represent Woodcock let me respond please
um thank you Marissa not being an
attorney
so that anything that's been said today
um is is not you know not being
presented by an attorney you're correct
and whether it applies only to 193 F
colon 9 4 to 193 f
um the whole chapter
um
and we all have our interpretations I'm
not going to give you mine okay
uh I I think it's a valid question
representative I mean thank you that was
my misunderstanding I thought we were
referencing Miss Chase because she was
an attorney and I appreciate her saying
it wasn't and you clarifying that
particularly Rick but the my question
remains and I think it's a huge question
is if this F9 that phraseology this
chapter means the entire 93f that opens
the whole gamut of issues Way Beyond
this one specific issue that the sponsor
of Mr cordelli is trying to get across I
think so I I love to have Clarity from
Miss Fenton or some other lawyer if you
know any lawyers on the committee thank
you
represent Tanner yes yes I noticed in
the participant log uh rep attorney
Fenton is on board and I was wondering
if we could get some information from
her
there
okay
good morning Diane are you familiar with
the question that's being talked about
here
I I am so just to clarify when there's
reference
um to the chapter the chapter is 193 F
in its entirety and you can see that
um if you flip back in your law book and
I'm probably the only one who has it
open in front of them but it's entitled
chapter 193 F so chapter 193 f is
inclusive of all the various
sub-provisions
um
yes is there a question representative
land yes that does parallel everything
follow up please yes thank you thank you
and thank you um uh for taking the
question
um because that was my question because
I read program as being a a larger piece
than what absolutely we just heard so
would that mean that this uh legal
course of action could be taken up or
any violation of 93f
safety
I
beat it that way but let me just
pull something up real quick because I
don't want to mislead you I think that
in the way I read this bill
I have way too many things open on my
computer so I I appreciate the
commitment
Frozen Woodcock I would agree with your
interpretation
that the way the bill is written
it would allow for a right of action if
there was any violation of any of the
provisions in RSA 193 f that is
inclusive of 193 F9
um
that is just my opinion of it so I have
to give the lawyer disclaimer
um right I don't work for you you
haven't retained me I work for the state
but that is my brief interpretation of
it
um but I will also say that
gross negligence or willful misconduct
is a very high standard
and I do agree with the prior speaker
that
um
you cannot just go into court with any
uh
you have something hurt my feelings and
and I want to file this I think this is
set up to in large part prevent the
abuses of the system I think what this
does my interpretation of it and having
sat through testimony from the prior
legislative session on this
um
this really is narrowly tailored at
those egregious moments in time and
unfortunately they they do happen
and so that is all that I'm comfortable
staying on on this bill I hope I've
answered your questions I'm happy to
take any others
yeah yes if I may rather than like yes
attorney you have answered my questions
thank you and I agree with you and
sometimes there are issues that need to
go and and we'll in negligence and
misconduct are are difficult to uh take
to a much higher level I agree 100 I was
concerned about the just that phrase ER
the chapter that it opens up the entire
193f as you concurred
um although the intent of the bill
sounds fine I think the way it's written
is going to open up all kinds of
mistakes
thank you thank you representative thank
you you're welcome
thank you very much
um
representatively thank you
yes uh
I uh
as the sponsor
agreed with uh
um
it's like to hear that
um that this applies to the entire
chapter 193 f and let me find out that
the purpose of this chapter
is and you can look at 193 F2 purpose
mid 10 is about building and cyber
bullying and protecting students from
physical emotional and psychological
harm that is the purpose of this chapter
and that is the purpose of this bill
thank you for informing us on the intent
the purpose of the bill uh
representative
I'm going to allow one more question
here it looks like grab some wood talk
you have another question well just yes
thank you representative it's not a
question it's a comment I don't want to
have representative cordelli leave off
with that statement
um it granted no one's questioned the
value of the intent of the bill but we
look at 93 when you go to 93 F4 that
lays everything out what we're supposed
to be doing no one suggesting is not
good it's just a poorly written bill
that expl that opens up the entire gamma
of 93 F and it's it's not written well
it's going to come back to bite us it
doesn't get to where it needs to be
thank you thank you very much I'm going
to call the motion at this point in time
uh the motion is for what 40 talk to
pass made by a versus a layout section
yes uh representative cordelli yes
representative bone yes
representative Ballard yes
representative yes representative
Moffitt yes representative Hobson yes
representative Andrus yes
representative Ford yes
representative way on yes representative
sodi yes representative Miler no
Representative no no
representative Shaw yes representative
Cornell
representative Tanner no
representative Allison oh
representative Mullen no
representative lay no representative
Woodcock no
representative luno will be writing the
report uh Minority Report very much
and represent Leon you have the majority
report yes thank you Mr chair thank you
very much okay the next bill of which
we're going to uh get is HB
422 and with that uh that's a a bill uh
let me read it here relative to the one
half credit required course in the
United States New Hampshire government
and Civics so you can all turn your
bills to 422 and I'll call upon
represent a Moffett for a motion famous
chair I'd like to move to retain this
measure at this time and representative
Hopson
makes a second so the motion on the
table is to retain HB 422 made by
representative moffatt and second by
representative Hobson representative
office do you care to speak to your
motion
I think that there's uh
I certainly support the intent of this
we have some issues with imposing uh
credit curriculum requirements and I
think we need to look at this further
yeah
okay thank you is there any further
discussion
yes represent Cornell
um I just want to say I think it every
student should take
um as much Civics as they possibly can I
checked to the programs of study in
Manchester
um and they do require one semester of
civics and they require it in the
freshman year because it's a requirement
for graduation so they want students to
take it and make sure they pass it in
case they don't they have time to
um make it up so while I think it's a
good idea I think many districts already
require if not all of them because I
think it's already in statutes that you
have to take a semester of civics but I
think even the wording of taking it in
Junior or senior year
it disrupts school districts who already
have made students take your freshman
year like I said just in case they they
don't pass it they do have time to make
it up in order for graduation so I'm
happy to vote for retaining this
thank you very much it's a further
discussion represent miles uh thank you
Mr chairman I want to thank
representative Moffat for making this
motion I know the passion that he has
for this many of us shared the same
passion for the issue of civics Etc but
I do think that this needs a little more
study because there are some serious
questions about its ramifications the
cost of the exam Etc so uh thank you
representative moffatt and I will be
discussion
thank you Mr chair for recognizing me
the only thing that I would like to say
is that with regards to high school
students that are already enrolled as
Juniors and seniors I'm concerned that
this would wreak havoc with their
long-range planning which may have begun
as representative Cornell said in grade
nine and also I think we need to take
into consideration that there are in
fact schools in New Hampshire uh that
have prescribed programs for students
that are in Junior and Senior year I'm
thinking about
some of the Career and Technical
programs that kids are are enrolled in
and uh the international Baccalaureate
program that have designated course
sequences and I'm not sure that there's
room in those schedules to add an
additional course thank you thank you
very much just a further discussion
yes I'd just like to follow up on
representative mullen's point of view I
know particularly at the school I taught
care Sarge where students had to be bust
down to Concord for their CTE courses
that um you know having a required
course in in the Junior and Senior year
was very difficult for them to fit in
um and much easier to fit in in the
freshman year so I would just reiterate
for the discussion just to wrap this up
it's my current belief that construction
right from our local responsibilities
and how you set your curriculum and your
syllabus up and of course the studies is
reflective of that district and that
school board
and Personnel within the school and for
all the reasons which I mentioned today
I also support retention
um
representative cordelli yeah
representative Paul yes representative
Allard yes representative yes
representative Moffitt yes
representative Hobb said yes
representative Andrus yes representative
for yes representative Leon yes
representative Sony yes
representative Miler yes
representative Lona yes representative
Shaw yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Ellison yes representative Mullen yes
representative lay yes representative
woodcock
thank you
yes I'm trying to get the Emu yes
Barbara
27.
hey
bro that's that's retained in our
committee it doesn't go anywhere those
out there
okay uh the the next bill I'd like to
address and jump in a little bit is HB
267.
um and 267 is relative to construction
standards for schools
and following this bill I'm going to
jump back to the other bill which we
have regarding the
um
establishing committee to study air
quality in school buildings so looking
at HB 267 first
and looking for a motion on 267 from
represent Hobson yes
[Music]
and foreign
so the motion has been made to retain HB
267 made by representative Hobson second
by represent Saudi uh represent Hobson
do you have any comments uh this
uh representative do you have any
comments no no occur with that okay uh
yeah thanks very much um yeah I'd
support retain on this too because I
think there was a lot of um sort of new
information that came to light during
the uh the hearing and uh you know I I
agree we want to have our school
buildings that that have acoustical
properties that are that are good for
all students and um and we could use
we've uh discussed school buildings
numerous times in various uh pieces of
legislation and discussions
including during the course of the
summer with a commission
and there are a number of issues
associated with schools that come
underneath the standards for schools and
what we look at in terms of an
application for our building a project
and acoustical is very important as is
HVAC and a number of our other systems
within our schools lighting Etc and we
know there's a relationship between all
those and achievement
and it's my hope seeing that this is
identified in a specific area which
deals with school building construction
standards by retaining this bill
we can go we can address acoustical
status yes but we need to address some
of the other issues which we have
associated with these standards we must
have in our schools
and so uh I'd like to see this become a
active subcommittee and seriously take a
look at uh all these systems we have
that comprise and necessary in our
schools to include the others that I've
mentioned and more
so um I don't see any further
hands up so let's have a vote on that
the motion this motion is to retain
house bill 267.
representative cordelli yes
representative ball yes
representative Aller yes representative
yes representative Moffett yes
representative Hobson yes representative
Andrus yes representative Ford yes
yes representative sodi yes
representative Miler yes representative
luno yes that is sure yes representative
yes representative Mullen yes
representative lay
yes there's Woodcock yes
representative Ladd yes
20-0
so we will retain that and uh I would
ask that if there are tools which would
like to actively get involved
um I won't I won't write down memes now
but be thinking about it on a something
maybe this will be an active
subcommittee uh it's been a topic of my
importance to us uh so I'd like to get
that one going as soon as possible uh to
be looking at construction standards in
our schools
uh the next bill which we will move to
is going back now uh to uh HB 339
establishing a committee to study air
quality in school building
uh I've looked for a motion on that one
from represent Hobson
Beyond and repson address are you making
the second the second emotion thank you
very much uh represent Hobson do you
have some comments thank you thank you
so this is a bill that establishes a
committee to study air quality in school
buildings
uh the recent pandemic that's shown a
light on the importance of clean air
their handling and air exchange and
school building
uh we receive grant money from the
federal government
um through this the cares act that has
been used to increase air quality air
handling and air systems throughout New
Hampshire
additionally laws have been passed in
previous sessions that require policies
to be developed in schools and annual
investigations into air quality in
public schools so I feel that this bill
further discussion
from uh
reps Andros do you have you give second
yeah I mean I feel that with covid-19
and All the Monies that school districts
have received during the last year and I
believe there's another amount coming
out to everybody I think they have done
many things to improve the air quality
in our schools and I think this bill is
unneeded at this time
thank you further discussion
representative
uh thank you Mr chair I'm very
disappointed in this motion
uh we had ample testimony
from people who are in the buildings
who work there daily
who have said that there are problems
here
notwithstanding the uh the
accommodations that have been made
through the pandemic
but there is a need to have this study
and we're always asking for us to look
at it in a deeper way very similar to
the loan that we just retained I don't
understand why we can't have both of
those together because they represent
problems that are taking place in
buildings right now
that are impacting student learning that
are impacting Personnel that are working
in those buildings
and with the testimony we had there was
ample evidence of a need for this
particular study so I'm very
disappointed in the Republican Congress
for for moving to it all this very
disappointed in this and I will be
voting no on this
uh I I'd like to just make one comment
uh for for the whole committee I think
it's the entire at least it's my intent
uh and looking at invest in 267 which is
relative to construction standards for
schools
that that goes well beyond acoustical
standards it goes into the air quality
standards which we're talking about
right now
and if in fact there is going to be a
subcommittee that's going to start out
immediately looking at that it's my
intent
have this topic which is inclusive
within 339 covered within this broader
bill right here which is relative to
construction standards yes you know talk
specifically to
um the acoustical but the chapter it's
again is dealing with construction
standards and so I believe that that
this bill will be addressed in that way
that we had some hands up right from San
Bruno no thanks very much Mr chair I I
agree with what representative Miler
said on this I mean uh and and and
honestly I agree with what you just said
um as well Rick that that that taking a
look in conjunction with the acoustic
standards
um study during the retain retaining 267
that that retaining 339 would uh would
make a lot of sense and and go into a
comprehensive summer study on um on air
quality and acoustic standards and maybe
any other building standards and then
we've got two retained bills one of them
that relates to Acoustics one of them
that relates to air quality that could
be used that could be amended to either
change those building standards but to
itl this
I think sends a terrible message to uh
to the general public to Granite Staters
to parents to families to school kids to
teachers to volunteers that that the New
Hampshire
um house doesn't care about indoor air
quality because even though a lot of
districts have implemented improvements
we we have we heard directly from the
the department of education's top
facilities person that we need to to to
have a close look at the indoor air
quality in our schools and um and I I
think I think passing this would be fine
but also I think retaining it would be
fine too so that we could we could do a
comprehensive summer study and we'll
have two vehicles with which to um to
amend to improve our building standards
going forward and I think that's a
that's a good message for granted
Staters
did you have your hand up yes I did Mr
chairman thank you
um just to reiterate and build on what
my two colleagues have uh pointed out uh
yeah you know a lot of there was
reference to covid funding and that's
directly related to issues
brought about by covet but we also had
much testimony about prior problems
long-standing HVAC problems in the
schools uh which cannot be necessarily
corrected using those funds and those
funds will disappear at a certain point
and second I mean this notion that you
can use 267 as the vehicle 267 very
explicitly and repeatedly in the bill
references only acoustical standards
that is all that we should be looking at
in that uh if if we're retaining that
and forming a subcommittee so I think
that you should retain 339 and combine
create a subcommittee to look at both of
them simultaneous it makes no sense to
do otherwise uh and again very
disappointed if if we're going to itl
this
um that just sends a direct message we
don't care about your basic health
in the schools we don't care about the
students Health the pupils Health the
Educators Health the staff Health okay
and we have a lot of systems that are in
in deep problems uh the Department of
Education made that clear to us and so I
think this should at the very least be
routine thank you thank you very much uh
representative
yeah I just um
had a question as to why because I know
when we talked about this beforehand
what we were planning on doing was
combining the two into one retain the
one it all the other just so we have one
[Music]
Mr chair I mean 339 very or not three
through nine two six seven explicitly is
about acoustical issues it references
acoustical standards uh the construction
standards are in regards to school
acoustics
and for a subcommittee to go somehow
beyond that is to go well beyond uh the
subject matter of the bill at hand which
is supposedly being studied by the
subcommittee thank you
further discussion representative
thank you representative
um and I don't want to feel like beating
the same dead horse
um but there may be a pointy here
somewhere I guess the representative may
say uh the convinced committee clearly
uh if we look at the on page
one line one two and three it talks
about study the air quality and pause
and improve the environmental factors of
schools it's not talking about new
construction it's not talking about
what's going to happen five years from
now we get all these new figures
together we're talking about looking at
the current schools in New Hampshire
which we know are are in a lot of them
in miserable State when it comes to air
quality the impact on Student Success
and the overall health of the faculty
and the students that are in them I
think this bill is is a whole different
ball of wax than just the construction
of the acoustical tile uh new building
construction this building to me is says
to every every teacher in New Hampshire
and every student parent in New
Hampshire we're concerned about what you
breathe when you go out of that building
and we're so concerned about it we're
going to do an entire study to come up
with the best recommendations how to
improve it that's what that says to me
this doesn't say anything about new
construction it's a whole different bill
I I would much concur as he's built this
committee go forward let them do their
work
thank you Mr
thank you representative Mullen thank
you Mr chair
um I I just want to point to out the
aspect of the term air quality that
sometimes gets overlooked air quality in
a school building is more than just
ventilation and HVAC in our community
alone uh well in our state actually in
New England I'm going to go as far as to
say why we build flat roofed buildings
in New England that leak all winter long
and result in mold problems and uh and
repairs that that that cost us all I
don't know but in our town mold has been
a problem and it was discovered because
the air quality became bad we had a bat
infestation in one of the buildings and
I'm talking like horror movie quality
stuff and the only reason that we knew
it was because the air quality became so
bad that people were getting affected
respiratorily so I have no problem
retaining both of these bills and if
your subcommittee wants to come out with
one bill that encompasses everything
so be it but
um yeah I think we're I think we're
missing an opportunity to deliver a
message that we truly want to take on
all forms of uh mishap that affect air
quality in our buildings thank you
thank you very much uh represent Tanner
uh thank you
um and I guess uh you know before before
covet even came asthma is a tremendous
uh problem in in schools with students
and
um they need air quality uh control also
buildings have been cobbled together
where I know in in my school one section
was built in you know
1969 and another section built in the
late 80s or 90s and an Edition was added
here or there I'm sure it happens in
many schools and lo and behold the
problem was uh air quality air air
ventilation
and it took a lot of effort on parents
part to actually get the school to look
at it
um at what was happening we also in
Sunapee have a school that's almost 100
years old that has the same problem as
the lob it was designed with Steam Heat
and uh has no ventilation station system
at all
and covid funds will not address all
these issues and nor would it point out
places for people to school districts to
look for these issues and to make some
um some mitigating uh
construction or whatever so I too think
that this bill is equally important as
the acoustic Bill and separate that it
is actually a bill that that has a lot
of need in in the state of New Hampshire
right now so I would I would really say
retain this bill make it make it an
important bill uh make it a statement
from this education committee that that
air quality has been a problem before
covid and probably will be afterwards
but we want to study it and come up with
some conclusions about and some
recommendations thank you
okay what I'm going to do at this point
in time before we go on with any further
questions kind of a recess uh the
committee for me for about 10 minutes
uh Democrats look caucus as well Mel
so okay so that so let's let's come back
at
the clock on the walls basically saying
it's
oh almost 10 30 here by you know MLB
time so let's come back about 15 minutes
makes it easier
okay
you get that paid yeah yeah so um so
we've got yeah so quarter of 11 uh
Democrats the caucus in our meeting room
so make sure we disconnect from this
back
yeah you use the use the time on your
phone
no she's not good that way we do not
have a caucus on this system
oh
hey we're back live
is everybody about to know we don't have
uh
foreign
so Rick who on the uh who won the
because I
was a team in two parts and the team was
playing the same team this Barnett
Village School
all right I I have a case because here I
have to get the kids in the car they
have to be at that for
game that starts at 6 30 and it gets
over around eight o'clock and that's and
it was held up at St J really
yeah something down the highway talking
with you going down I am 91.
yeah how's Andrew doing this this season
well he's not playing because he had the
operation that he had children's
hospital and he went through like a 10
hour surgery for that concave chest and
they had to go into the pack he's only
getting 70 yet what they call tall man
syndrome
where
you only have 70 air and you know you
don't have to worry about that Glenn
uh he's he's doing much much better now
and he's working with his coach up there
doing some preliminary things dealing
with
um
you know uh working with his legs and
that uh but he won't be able to do
anything really active for about three
months and then he's gonna be back
playing golf in Saint Lawrence
University what's he about six seven now
how big is his shoe
oh it's like you know it's huge it's I I
can't tell you his father is same height
wow it's nine
and and I was the shortest one in my
you know you can't go to LLB and buy him
a pair of shorts
you've got to go through the here on the
tailor and get a mate
now they have told us because big and
tall is usually big around the waist
right yeah so hey let's get on with this
bill okay
380 chatter about my grandson
thank you for the interest of us
um I'm going to recognize representative
Hobson for our um
her to speak for a second
IPL
we're gonna I'm gonna make a new Motors
to retain the bill
I take back my second to the motion okay
so we no longer have a motion to it all
this bill now I will recognize represent
Hobson for a motion please yes I'd like
I second the motion to retain this bill
house uh what is it 339 yeah yes 339.
all righty uh would you like to speak to
your motion please representative Hobson
sure
um we uh are going to retain this bill
um to work on some of the data
collections around their air quality
their family
um study the study the matter a little
further
[Music]
representative uh thank you Mr chair I
want to thank represent Hobson for the
the motion that she just put forward I
think this will provide us an
opportunity to really look at this thing
and as a representative Mullen said this
is more than just air I mean there there
are other issues that are in that HP
HVAC system that is having a definite
problem on students and Personnel thank
you very much representative Hobson for
okay so is there a further discuss
I don't um I forgot to take my hand down
sorry that's okay
representative cordelli
thank you chairman uh I would just like
to mention that uh this week I talked
with the director of Paris and Esther
funding at the Department of Education
and uh next week is expected to get an
online system available to districts to
apply for an investor two funds which is
over 140 million dollars
and specifically
included in the allowable expenses uh
plaster to our air quality issues
um HVAC systems and even doors and
windows so
um you might have your districts for
okay uh folks I'm going to
um if there's no further uh discussion
on this I'm going to have the third call
enroll the motion is to retain HB 339
representative cordelli yes
representative bone yes representative
Allard yes representative lakis yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Hobson yes representative
Andrus yes representative board yes
instead of Leon yes representative sodi
yes representative Miler yes
yes because I'm sure yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Ellison
representative Mullen
yes representative light yes it's under
Woodcock yes representative glass yes
unanimous 20-0 thank you very much
uh so I will be putting together a
committee to look at this uh both issues
um be it a committee of the whole or a
subcommittee depending on how many
people uh want to be participants in
this as I've stated before I believe
this extremely important issue
uh and and both these fields are
important and it goes further that we
have other
systems within our schools which need
attention
um so I hope we can get on it as quickly
as possible I think this is almost even
a better way of doing it than waiting
for a bill to go through the Senate if
it makes it through the Senate uh where
they're not really a pro uh supporting
committee development this year but then
to have to wait for something to be
signed in we can start right now and we
can answer the the spring months we have
to try to work with Amy Clark and
company over there and other
professionals to get some answers to
these real important issues thank you
very much Paul
uh I'd like to now return to HB 319
regarding students in this University
and Community College systems of New
Hampshire to pass the United States
citizenship and immigrations Services uh
Civics naturalization test
um I'd like to look to represent for a
promotion place
uh yeah thank you Mr chair I'd like to
make promotion of the amendment that was
sent to the committee uh a couple days
you've got to put a motion on the floor
first before you deal with the amendment
yes I like to roll over
OTP uh as amended
okay
now just
is fine and then
um
foreign
[Music]
which does reflect the concern has been
we've received from uh ccsnh to the U.S
usnh
so the amendment uh clearly exempts
certificate programs it also incense
graduate and postgraduate
programs another concern
uh the amendment pushes back the
implementation date to January 1st 2023.
that should just move forward that would
give all priorities plenty of time to
prepare and Implement uh I also point
out that uh if HB 320 the high school
requirement which has already passed the
house if that should move forward
that would in large part satisfy the
Collegiate requirement that we're
looking at here
uh and also point out that a number of
other states have already put this into
place Florida has Missouri just passed
the subjects and extensions so uh this
is something that's being done elsewhere
uh I do want to point out that it can be
administered online I've had
conversations with the university and
Community College people
so the fact that this can be very easily
uh put online so that students can take
it at their convenience uh at any point
during their college Journey taking as
many times as they need to have taken
online there's no need for
the College of suspended time creating
the test administering the test or
anything that we're breaking the test
and finally uh we certainly since we
need or the desire for this and I uh
this bipartisan sport I hope it was more
and thank you Mr chair thank you are
there further comments from the uh
no I just think that awareness if
nothing else is uh extremely important I
think that that too many kids are even
graduating from college and don't even
know the answers to this question so I I
just I don't see anything wrong with it
uh it's not a great burden and I think
we live in the United States or America
I mean I don't know these things right
and that's how I feel strongly about
thank you uh further comments
representative uh Cornell
I don't know exactly how this will work
I help representative Moffitt could
explain so they're not going to take the
naturalization test that's officially
online and have that scored and graded
because that cost 725 dollars to do that
um so is the University or Community
College going to
put the online test on some server that
they have and the students will take
that or I don't I can't I don't know how
sure now thanks for the question uh sure
the the uh
the proposed measure specifically refers
to the 108 assessment in over 120
questions would be part of the
assessment uh what can and if this moves
forward what uh I expect wouldn't be
done would be simply for the
institutions to put this online I uh
I've taught in both the university and
Community College systems and the
university system has a little what they
call a little capability in blackwoods
community college system had
and uh it's very easy to take 128
questions presented myself many times
and just simply put it on a program and
make it available to be taken to the
students so uh there's no 725 charge uh
it's so it's very easy to put it online
and for the students who uh take it at
and yes you may
so if they're taking it at home at their
Leisure online there's nothing to
prevent them from already having all the
answers printed out and looking at them
while they're taking the test
I'm sure the specifics in the
administration uh ultimately we would
leave to the uh institutions but it's
like any other exam I have done many uh
assessments and exercises and exams
online and we're asking part of thousand
security measures that can be taken and
as far as stabbing the uh the questions
the questions of public knowledge uh
they're out there and uh you know as far
as that specific concern about having
the questions available to take the
assessment uh my biggest concern is that
this information wash over and it's
noticed and if they know it one way or
another the specifics of the
administration uh again uh we would
leave to the institutions
Roxanna Ellison
thank you Mr chair uh I guess I would
like to question the basic premise that
if college and university students could
pass this test and I guess the same
thing is true with high school students
that passing this test is any way
connected to being an active articulate
intelligent citizen uh I guess I'm
speaking as someone a high school former
High School teacher who spent four years
teaching year-long U.S government
courses which was a required course for
all seniors uh and this this particular
approach I think we're kidding ourselves
if we think this is going to get
students to be where we want them to be
or yeah adults to be where they want to
be I mean being able to answer a
question or questions about who was
president during World War One or being
able to name one Indian tribe or being
able to tell if both the President and
Vice President no longer serve who
becomes the president those
in my mind as an educator of social
studies are not linked at all to where
we want our students to be when they
come out so I I would be voting against
the motion
reps L.A
thank you Mr chair
um
a couple of things here
going back to the point that was raised
obviously the answers are all out there
already
if there's going to be any sort of
proctoring or any sort of controls that
would require
um University or Community College to be
more directly engaged it would be more
complicated than simply just putting up
a test because if you just simply put up
the test that anybody can take at any
time it is very easy
to Simply have the set of answers
and just type away and put the answers
in this is not how I would ever give an
exam
I've taught for over 30 years in higher
education full-time I teach U.S history
I'm obviously deeply concerned about the
issue of civics
not only do I teach U.S history
particularly political history uh but
obviously I've been in the legislature
so I have a clear interest here and the
concern that we see here that's being
expressed by everybody and I share that
concern
is a concern that has been uh repeatedly
voiced and demonstrated through polls
surveys Etc all the way back to the 19
teens
okay
um this is not a new issue
and simply giving a test like this
will accomplish nothing
because it is accomplished nothing in
the past when you do it this way if
you're going to teach Civics you need to
connect it to something that is real
that is part of the students lives that
they can use that they can make their
own simply answering questions will not
do that this will not and this notion
that somehow there'll be some process of
osmosis that will make the student a
better citizen by knowing these little
factoids it is not going to result in
any such results at all uh so you know I
I think it is
the motive behind it is is good
but the approach is completely
mistaken and and it does not follow what
everything we know about education and
how students learn particularly today
um this will not do the trick whatsoever
I also would you know question why are
we sticking with the 128 exam uh
question exam when the U.S United States
is now using the 100 question exam from
2008. the USCIS is uh in the process
right now of phasing out the 128 exam or
a question exam and is now moving back
to the 100 question exam so again I I
think you know the motive is fine but
this will not even remotely accomplish
and in fact what this will do it will
diminish students interest in Civics
because it will quite clearly send the
message
that we just apply a simple Band-Aid we
just apply a simple test which carries
no real meaning to it it is completely
disconnected to everything else in their
educational progress
um and that you simply do this here are
the answers
regurgitate them take the test now
you're fully educated by our standard on
Civics and I think that's a pretty low
standard to adopt so I will have to vote
against this thank you thank you
representative yes
and without due respect uh
representative Blake the way I look at
it differently
and and it's perfectly fine I understand
where you're coming from
I always felt that
um
oh in in today's world we
we can look up anything we want if I
want to know the answer to something uh
is John Wayne still alive whatever you
type it into Google and there's your
answer
what to me what it does is
as a part of educating kids in Civics
this is not the only thing you know you
do this test and and you're you're done
you know everything you need to know
that isn't the way I look at it it's an
awareness
of the country it's like giving the kids
an open bookcast and and many teachers
do that they they give kids a quiz and
it's it's an open book test your
you're searching for the information
you're reading the information
you are coming up with an answer and
you're not necessarily going to remember
all of that but you're being exposed to
it and I think it's part of the total
picture of learning about civics
government the United States of America
all that put in together it's just a
small part but everybody would have to
do that so they at least got that small
part if they managed to wiggle their way
out of any other Civics courses or
history or anything else they would have
a little piece
so that they have some sort of an
awareness and and that's the way I look
at it it's probably a very demented way
of looking at it but it's my opinion and
and I think it's it's important and
especially for a lot of kids who maybe
aren't uh good memorizers here I am are
um you know just to be exposed to it and
to have to find the information or or to
recall the information
it'll remain there something will come
up something will stick with them and
and that's just the way I look at it
thank you Mr chair let me first begin by
assuring representative Shaw that she is
not demented
I I have worked in the field I know
demented when I see it and it's not
representative Shaw
um I appreciate that you're quite
welcome
so uh I I thank you uh representative
Moffett for taking my question first I
have a question for you would you
believe representative Moffett
that I am old enough that I remember
when it used to be printed on materials
in school buildings that we were not
allowed to photocopy or Xerox any
testing materials without either
purchasing the license or contacting the
owner or whatever the case may be so my
question to you is who has the
proprietary rights to this exam
and
um our college is going to be
responsible for either buying a license
or contacting immigration services or I
I mean do we know I guess my question is
do we know that we can just freely uh
take it off of the internet
sure thank you for your question uh yeah
the exam is in the public domain so uh
it's been used uh
100 question versions
in the 128 version the same way uh yes
it's the public domain it's great for
thanks very much uh represent the mafia
you had a comment you wanted to make uh
yeah I think this year uh I just also
want to say that I do not think
representative at all and I I do want to
say very quickly I I do completely
disagree with with uh representative and
with uh representative sentiments
um this is not intended to solve
everything and we I or we have never
said it's intended to solve everything
and also these are not irrelevant
factoids I'll say that again I don't
think these are irrelevant factoids
these are the basic fundamentals and
tools that that students or people or
adults or anyone should have uh if
they're going to have a sense of how our
government works and so I I completely
distributed their development factories
and then the last I think the 128 versus
100 100 questions
test yes we specifically asked 128 uh
you know a business a little bit more
rigorous but also so there'd be no
confusion uh because there are multiple
uh citizenship testing specifically
identified the 2020 version so there
will be no uh no diffusion
thank you very much uh representative
thank you representative Ladd I have two
questions one is for representative
moffatt and one I I I'd ask if you would
allow me uh 90 seconds on a different a
similar topic and involved topic I
regards this to representative Moffett
um I just want to be clear uh are you
are you assuring us that students at the
cause level will not be
charged any money Administration scoring
on the college credits for this and I
say that because student debt New
Hampshire is one of the leading reasons
we don't have young to stay in New
Hampshire so can can you assure me that
this legislation is not going to cost
college students anything
uh thank you representative uh what I
can certainly say is that this should
not cost anyone anything like someone
the percent institution always can try
to attach a fee to something but uh
don't you give it to your question uh
this is already this exam has already
been given in this being given across
the country uh three uh and it's in the
public domain and uh so this should not
um I would like to allow I have the to
allow me to take 90 seconds and get
people involved in this democracy
I I don't know where you're going with
that I'm going I'm going exactly about
this bill I'm not going to Veer off it
90 seconds
okay thank you representative Ladd and
the committee I'm going to ask all of
you to take out a pencil or a paper take
out a pencil or paper everyone including
you representative I can see you take
out everyone
now this test requires that people with
65 new younger folks we're going to let
you use the 65 year old version
get five out of eight to get a minimum
of a sixty they to pass the test this
test has eight categories so I'm just
going to give you eight questions and
you can write the answers because as
representative Norfolk just said it's a
basic fundamental tool that everyone
should know how government works so 90
seconds first question
Section 8 how many amendments the United
second question
how many voting members are in the House
third question
what is the purpose of the Tenth
Amendment
come on jump in
first question
I see you fourth question
is it important for all men ages 18 to
25 to register for Selective Service and
why
thank you
fifth question
why is the Federalist Papers important
what was that one why are the Federalist
Papers important
sixth question almost done
I can't write that fast if you even know
the answer you don't yeah
I can't answer why why that fast what
amendment gives citizenship to all
last question
why did the United States hit the World
War One
oh
why does the flag have 13 stripes
now all you need to do that is get five
out of those eight to pass and be a good
that's all it takes
so the other so you check this is
self-checking self-checking the first
answer how many how many uh amendments
27.
how many voting members 435 excellent
are you cheating you're a teacher
oh
what's the purpose of the Tenth
Amendment reserved powers to the states
the federal government correct let
someone else have to cheat will you okay
I'm sorry I know these
is it important for all men ages 18 to
25 to registered elective service
we have three we have three retired
Offices here somebody should have that
representative Ladd moffatt Allen the
law
that's not why
amen for the service of the country
thank you Barbara don't have to mention
either
what what amendment can citizenship to
all persons born in the U.S
it'd be 14. why did the U.S getting
unless representative cordelli because
he's so excited here why the U.S enter
World War One
thinking of the Lusitania
economics
I was gonna say money is money answers
and finally why are the 13 stripes 13
colonies
okay so you get five out of eight you
could be a U.S citizen Barber
thank you for that option representative
land I appreciate the uh allowing that
so everybody knows the test we're
talking about
in regard to The Selective Service I
don't think it really does much of
anything seeing that I got my draft
notice how I came home from Vietnam
I was number 10 and I was in basic I
hear you
okay we're going to go on to the next
question representative Milo uh thank
you uh thank you chairman Ladd uh
representative moffatt you said that uh
this bill would exempt uh those who are
taking uh certificate courses or or do I
yes uh
I think it's on line seven actually
[Music]
it specifically says degree requirements
okay thank you very much
uh representative uh
ways and you pass the test you can ask a
question thank you Mr chairman
look I I just want to respond to some of
the comments that were responding to me
um and I appreciate the views of my
colleagues most certainly and
these these these points that are raised
here on this test if they are not
connected
to anything substantive uh whether it be
in an additional course whether it be as
part of the overall curriculum of a
student
they are simply factoids okay students
will not retain them students will
retain things they use and that are
connected in a living way to their
education that is not what is being
proposed here
and so what will happen is it will
simply be an additional hurdle that a
student needs to go through
they will simply have the answers next
to them again I know how students
operate and in particularly in an online
environment where there is no particular
vested interest on the part of the
University or the college
to Proctor the exams or anything of the
sort
um and just let the student go ahead and
take it this will not have anything and
and I would particularly I mean there
were comments made that this is
um and points made that this is similar
to an open book test or
um it is
um you know part of the total picture
and and yes it could be
but just simply giving the exam is not
similar to an open book test in an exam
I'm actually giving an exam tomorrow
where my students can bring in in U.S
history where they can bring in any
notes that they want to bring on the
exam sheet okay and so the process of
having them develop their notes in
advance is helping them to learn okay
but here the answers are already
available it's all there it's all laid
out for them uh and so there will not be
learning happening it just simply won't
and I I fear that what we are doing here
is it's not even applying an effective
Band-Aid to a long-standing issue of a
failure of civics now Civic Civic
knowledge Civic awareness much more
useful would be having students go to
town meetings much more useful would be
having students engaged in particular
ways whether in the political process
um or you know how however but simply
giving a task of 128 questions
is not going to do it
I'm afraid so again I have to reiterate
um I think we're getting close to where
we should start calling the role here
thank you very much Mr chair
um something we haven't talked about and
there you know we did we didn't have
substantial testimony on on 319 but the
one that actually raised the the most
significant concern
um to me was the representative from
nachi who um who spoke to the um the
institutions ability to to attain and
retain
certification
requirement in view of um certain
graduation requirements being prescribed
by legislators and legislatures and
politicians and um and you know I you
know she really she pointed that out as
a is a very strong concern I think we're
also probably going to have you know
similar concerns when we when when the
work group on the merger convenes on
tomorrow
with respect to um to higher education
um
accreditations and and I'm I guess I'm
not sure what the I don't think the
amendment does anything to to address Ms
O'Brien's um
um concerns on this and and frankly I
think um I I you know I
I think I think we we as a committee
should be really sure about what the
what the accreditation impact would be
on our um on our University system on
our community college system that I
think work with in terms of matriculated
students and undergraduate and
Associates and bachelor's programs
probably is in the 50 to 60 000 student
range
um Statewide so I think the impact could
be potentially very very significant on
not only the the number of students but
on the um the certifications of these
colleges
um and how the certifications
you know also impact everything from up
from you know Federal
um
um uh Federal research grants and
everything else that's tied to
being a certified institution so so I
just hope we're not moving forward
blindly um
uh you know on this on this really what
what I think is a very important very
significant bill
um for our state institutions
thank you okay with that I'm going to
ask the uh clerk to call the role where
we're dealing with the amended language
to 319 as reflected in Amendment
0726 h
d uh emotions to uh thought to pass
representative perdelli yes
representative representative Aller yes
representative yes representative
Moffett yes representative Hobson yes
representative Andrus yes that board yes
representative Leon yes and Saudi yes
representative Myler no no
representative Shaw yes representative
Cornell no
would you like to put a motion forward
now please Mister
yes
uh bill before
otpa
we did
further discussion
not seeing any uh representation would
you please uh call the role
representative cordelli yes
representative yes representative Allard
yes representative wakeus yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Hobson yeah
representative Andrus yes Senator Ford
yes then lay on yes it says sorry yes
representative Miler no there's that
luno no that are sure yes representative
Cornell
representative Tanner no representative
Ellison
representative Owen no it said like no
no
yes 12 8.
I hope Channel 9 shows the uh the test
good to see that tonight Mr chair uh
just a point of order don't we usually
vote on the amendment first
we did because it I thought we changed
it around so that we voted
okay sorry
representative representative lay will
sorry
what is the IPL representative way
okay so Professor moffatt will write the
go ahead and not go ahead Professor Lynn
thank you I'd love to see University
have some
discussion on this okay we're going to
go to the next bill that's on the docket
today and it's hb441
is requiring the universal declaration
human rights to be placed in all public
schools
and with that I'd like to recognize
okay so we have a motion on the floor
IPL on HP 441 made by reps in a bone and
second by representative Saudi uh
represent Boone be care to speak to your
motion yes this is a
Declaration of Human Rights done 70
years ago
in some cases outdated
and
if schools want to put it up they can
but
um the problem is there are some just
because the country the United States is
a member of the United Nations doesn't
mean we as citizens of the United States
a sovereign country should be subjected
to any Declarations of a non-us agency a
country or otherwise also at the last
minute it's going to be a 28-day issue
also even though the the Declarations
can be given free and whatnot they still
have to be posted put up and maintained
and there's no such requirement
um
it's fine as a teaching tool
but I find that this bill is a jumped
are there any comments
elsewhere within the committee
not not seeing any hands fights so we
will go ahead Madam clerk can you please
and the motion is itl on 441 Universal
preparation human rights
motion is Ito
uh representative cordelli yes
representative bull yes representative
Allard yes representative lankas yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Hobson yes representative
Andrus yes representative board yes
representative Leon yes they're Saudi
yes representative Miler yes the luno
yes I'm sure yes representative Cornell
yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Allison oh
representative Mullen yes representative
lay no
representative Woodcock new
two for agree and three and three for
disagree
I think he agreed
no
okay that must be represent Uno's dog
then
I was Brave Brady Bach and Brady the
traitor
[Music]
whoa okay
the question is whether or not we put
this on consent uh Steve what's your
feeling on that or do you want to do a
Minority Report you want to do minority
part Steve
I'd rather go with consent consent okay
put it on consent uh uh chairman
report coming to you you don't get to
okay
um
we have about 25 minutes here before
lunch I hope we're gonna do Hospital 69
next
hb69 has a bill relative to the display
um
hours
kidding me is there a second you're
kidding me
representative
[Music]
you you did second that yes okay we have
a motion made by uh represent Hobson and
and second by representative cordelli uh
reps and Hobson would like to speak to
your motion
so this bill
[Music]
of the United States
display in school buildings and I
believe there is appropriation in there
for
um
acceptance of donations so this
issue and it's not a requirement
s
um
represent like this
yeah the difference between this bill
and the previous one is the previous one
was a mandate and this one is just in
May
that's that's really the big difference
representative uh Miler did you have
your hand up
well I might as well sure thank you Mr
chair
even though this is a May thing
um it's it still is uh it's it's similar
to the one we just we just uh put in uh
itl I just don't understand why we're
recommending to school districts to do
these kinds of things I mean if they
want to do it they can do it anyway now
we're trying to put this in law that
permits them to do that I just don't
think it's necessary uh this is another
another example of of uh of government
overreach we hear that all the time so
uh
absolutely I just disagree with this the
other thing is that this is our motto
that was that was placed in and in some
people
they don't believe in God
and this purpose Unum was our original
motto which we should have kept to begin
with
but that's not where we are right now so
I just think it's I just think it's not
necessary thank you uh representative uh
crayon
uh thank you the one of the other
important differences here is that this
is the United States motto and we were
talking about the United Nations
declaration I believe that that
she reps on woodcock
thank you Mr chair and I'd like to speak
to this again
um as they did in the hearing
um hb69 it's not a bill that's needed
it wasn't needed last session if you
recall it was done exactly on this day
last of March 11th
um it wasn't needed then it's not needed
today
the bill doesn't change when I order a
thing today it can't already happen
and I quote from the bill the school
board May provide and later on I said
the school board May accept yada yada
last year representative Ladd and I
quote you said this bill does nothing
and he was right then and you're right
now
from a legislative point of view why are
we making all the law that says nothing
requires nothing does nothing
I mean moving beyond this this
legislative foolishness if you will I
break through the Elijah point that
representative uh Dr Ladd talked about
the other day this isn't 1956 when
President Eisenhower in concert with by
the way Billy Graham worked together to
make Christianity and patriotism into
this weapon against the uh Godless
communists
and please don't think of my lack of
support for this bill comes from my
place my lack of personal patriotism or
my non-belief in God that's not the case
I'm a proud Army veteran I'm Deacon in
my church so that's irrelevant to the
topic
our personal beliefs yours and mine
should not dictate school policy today
is 2021. many of us outside our door our
house door especially during mud season
when you may have a mat that says
welcome
the math does two things it keeps the
mud out of the house if you live in the
North country and it allows your friends
to be welcome to your home
using a similar if you will education
metaphor for schools are the homes and
the students are our guests but by
putting the national motto in God we
trust at the front of the school it does
not present a welcome sign it actually
says you're not welcome here
you may say to whom you may ask is the
sign to not welcoming and I say to all
of us students and their parents and
visitors that don't necessarily hold the
same judio Christian beliefs that you
and I may have
think of the population of children in
the backgrounds that they bring to the
schools today in 2021 this is not the
same demographic as 1956.
as representative Mila said maybe it's
time to recall the national model that
was established in 1782 out of one in
many that fits in 2021 and I'd go on
record asking him to reject this bill on
it yell it thank you thank you very much
uh representative you're hands up yes
thank you
um if part one was the only thing that
was in this I would say yes it does
nothing and there's no point in it but
part two bait is the protection of the
school who does choose to put this up I
don't know if any schools will but if
they do
part two is the important part is that
the Office of the Attorney General shall
defend the display so we're trying to
shortcut any lawsuits that may happen
should a school decide to do this
um
and say yes they definitely are still
allowed
um I don't know that any schools will
but I will say after 9 11. many schools
on their big bull bar Billboards said In
God We Trust so
um they may and this
part two is the important it says that
yes and they will be defended for doing
so thank you
clarified with uh representative said
that our school on 9 11.
uh 20 years ago right after it all the
big bubbles and all three of our schools
outside had and God we trust on them
nobody told them to do it they did it on
their own so
this says hey if you do it now you're
further further Comics representative
thank you Mr chair
my question is who protects and defends
the interests of the students who don't
believe in God I personally do not
believe in the judeo-christian God I do
not accept that
um my children do not believe yet they
attended public school and if this sign
is out front what does it say to my
children
what does it say to them
thank you
thank you very much
um
representation yeah I representative
Wade just said uh uh basically what what
I was thinking is that
um I I think that that this is isolating
students who
believe in a different religion it might
still be God but
um they don't recognize it in that name
or whatever and I think we're we're
singling out
um
children by by
having this in the schools I think if
they want to put it up as an
informational thing as part of a you
know historical uh display with you know
mottos and documents and things like
that but to just have it displayed as
like here's you put something like that
in a school on display it means that
this is what you live by and and I just
think it's out of place and and uh I
would definitely disagree with the
thought to pass on this
further comments represent what talk to
your hands up yeah and one just uh just
to address the comments have made
representative very quickly no one's
suggesting no one is suggesting that
it's illegal we're not suggesting that
at all it is legal part two just says if
someone takes you to court the state
will pay the money so that's all it says
the state will come to you and pay the
bill it is legal that's not the question
it's not a problem it's not moral and
it's not welcoming
thank you very much
uh sorry do you have a comment yeah
um
well it's just like it's just being said
yes
that's it
yeah in much the same fashion that when
somebody sneezes and you say bless you
are you endorsing God in that statement
you're more or less endorsing the
culture that you're in
and that doesn't necessarily mean that
it's God that you're endorsing
you're endorsing the establishment of
the culture that you're in
and I don't feel that uh
it would bother people who are atheist
um that's basically it thank you very
thank you and my little hand raising
thing on the on the panelist uh board
isn't working so that's why I'm waving
madly
um I agree with uh what people have said
about how it it is it makes schools a
little bit less than welcoming
um for all people and I think that's
that's an important part of our public
schools that we open to everybody that
we uh recognize their culture and that
we um we don't uh try to intimidate them
in some way which I think some people
would find this intimidating I I also
think that the fact that we have that
that uh part of the law that are part of
this bill that says that um the state's
going to pick up the tab if you get sued
indicates that this is a contentious
issue that that uh putting it out there
is going to mean that it's going to
offend some people and some people are
going to be
um anxious about it and some people are
going to uh create the diversion by it
or or they'll they may not take it to
court but they they may bring it to the
school board and is that really what we
want to encourage at this point in our
nation when we have so much
division right now to put some red flag
in front of some people I I just find
that
um
not what I want to do thank you thank
you very much uh representative uh
Andrus
uh according to what I have read and
this is I have it right in front of me
right now back in 2018
Florida was one of seven states that
passed laws requiring or permitting
schools and other public buildings to
post and God we trust and so this issue
that we have right before us I realize
is pros and cons but it's not a new
thing they've passed laws in other
thank you very much Mr chair and um you
know I agree with a lot of what's been
been said um I do think however that
Representatives Lucas and Tanner really
sort of got to the um got to the point
on this where um where you know Roman 1
let some Deuce you know says they can do
something that they already have you
know they can do
um but Roman 2 puts the Attorney General
in a very unique position the Attorney
General normally can choose what um laws
to defend or not and this puts the
Attorney General in a position where
they shall defend the uh the display and
um and on other bills
that I've seen where a um now a mandate
is placed upon a department we've we've
seen fiscal notes
um on that
um I mean there was talk earlier this
week I think about a fiscal note for a
twenty thousand dollar thing and I think
that's pales in comparison to what um to
what a a defense
could be and um and I think this is
probably a very good example of a bill
where where we should seek
um a fiscal note from the LBA and get
some get some input from the Department
of Justice in terms of what this would
be what this would would require in
terms of in terms of Defending a school
district on this because I think as as
many people have said and I think uh on
on all sides of this issue that it's a
contentious issue and uh and certainly
will spark a um a lawsuit in any
District that does it AG will be on the
hook to uh to defend the school district
I think we should know what the cost is
thank you very much uh representative
Holland
thank you Mr chair for recognizing me
um
I had the same reaction to reading this
bill that I did when I read uh the
previous Bill 441 and that was that I
for saw my constituents being upset if I
voted in favor of the bill
and I say that universally whether it
was the human rights thing or In God We
Trust I looked at both of those bills
and thought if I vote in favor of these
bills I am going to have constituents
that are going to be really upset over
the divisiveness of the bill
and so I uh respectfully chose to vote
with the uh the motion on the the itl
motion on the Human Rights bill
um I I have to say that I feel that in
voting against
ought to pass on this I want to make it
perfectly clear that it does not reflect
my own personal beliefs uh in God or not
what it reflects is my respect for all
of my constituents thank you
thank you uh Leon
no represent Hobson excuse me
um
brings people
with the spirit of being united as the
United States citizens
and um
we all come from different
countries we all have Heritage in
different countries
of reading that the United States style
is
us together it makes us more of life
uh so I just I just wanted to add that
um
for example that I think that schools
if they are confronted with uh
constituents that are uncomfortable with
this most likely would not put it up
if they want to
welcome to and this is amazing
legislation so thank you thank you very
much uh representative
yeah I just wanted to say that all of
our money says In God We Trust which we
handle all the time and
um I haven't seen any lawsuits or upset
or people not wanting to handle money
because they're atheists and it says In
God We Trust so it is our state motto
and it is on our money I mean our
federal motto and it is thank you
okay
okay I don't see any other hands up in
the air on this particular field so um
would you please call the role the
motion is not hb69 displaying the
national model the schools uh
promotionless made by representative
Hops and second bye everyone
representative and the motion is often
pass
representative cordelli yes
representative yes representative Aller
no
representative Hobson yes
representative Andrus yes
represented forward yes
representative Leon yes representative
sodi yes I said Myler
no
represent Luna no representative Sean no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no
I am Allison oh
representative Mullen no
representative way
will there be a minority yes
representative Tanner will issue that
report
okay
just to be clear I apologize for
interrupting
um if if no other emotions are going to
come forward and you guys have a no
recommendation
um both sides will need to to author a
report yeah right that's what we're
preparing right
a statement yes thank you
you're ready to report yeah and we're
writing the other representative Tanner
okay I think what we're going to do is
because the lob time says we're
approaching 12 o'clock here
so what we're going to do is we're going
to take a break here
and
uh we're gonna come back here let's say
in 45 minutes is that good enough
anybody need more than that I think that
should be apple
um
you could give us a specific time just
because I I'm not I don't trust the lob
is quite on the same time as like the
computers here I'm showing 1153 right
now what is the clock there say uh so
what I'm going to say to you that that
obviously 12 45. thank you thank you
I have seven minutes
[Music]
foreign
um okay welcome back for all the
going down through this uh we have set
up for today and the next one after 1869
is hb5 581.
relative to the burden of proof and
specialists
thanks very much
I would like to move lots of plants on
House Bill 581 from relatives
yeah thank you very much so we have
emotional for our past 581 made by
representative Deli and second by rep
Sarah Moffett
this bill is about
um
a little bit more
culture burden of proof and due process
[Music]
we're having a hard time hearing
represent cordelli I'm sorry
[Music]
did you hear representative cordelli now
representative
let's have him speak and we'll tell you
yes can you get better now much better
thank you very much thank you
representative Vlad yes yes it appears
as he moves back and forth from the
microphone that's what's happening
instead of just being right there he's
moving
so what it is we have one of these
lights that's on the top of the desk
here and it's aimed at me and not
towards him I don't know
all right so just to repeat the motion
is ought to pass and uh this bill is
intended to level the playing field in
due process hearings and put the burden
of proof on the school district
they have the resources
uh they have the lawyers
um
where now installed
parents have to pay in case in some in
many cases uh twenty thousand dollars
enough if they want to take a case to uh
due process hearing this will level the
playing field and I think we owe it to
the parents of children with special
needs to make sure that they get a fair
hearing as to the services that are
needed by their children which is
thank you
uh representative Mullins thank you very
much Mr chair uh yes Mr chair I would
like to introduce an amendment
to House Bill 581
it is amendment zero seven five nine H
and you all should have received a copy
you repeat that number please
representative yep zero seven five nine
h
m
are you moving on to pass that
representation I am
I second that motion
I'm I'm waiting to see if the chair has
yes I have that copy here
uh are you making a motion to move five
eight one or the amendment to that
age I am so I second that motion Mr
chair okay so with a motion that's been
made on zero seven five nine age made by
representation
Myler uh representative
I would thank you very much Mr chair
okay so full transparency on this
I have gone back and forth back and
forth back and forth between the two
positions on this bill uh so many times
that I have not only driven myself crazy
I've probably driven my colleagues crazy
too because I've talked about it so much
um
there is I believe that there is Merit
in all positions on this this particular
topic but I am not sure that everybody
um has an equal understanding of the
processes that go on at the Department
of Education
uh I'm not sure myself that I understand
both the intended and unintended
consequences of changing the burden of
proof and so uh this amendment seeks to
turn the bill into a study committee
that would do three things
first it would give us time via the
study committee and then the report of
the study committee back to the full
committee to familiarize uh everyone
with the extent and the depth of the
processes that currently exist at the
doe for dispute resolution
the second thing that it would do is uh
allow us an opportunity to examine the
processes the responsibilities and the
potential outcomes of Shifting the
burden of proof from the school district
where it excuse me from the the
presenting party it actually the burden
of proof belongs to whoever is bringing
the case but uh 581 would shift that
burden to the school district and I'm
not sure that we have
I certainly have not had adequate time
to convince myself that I know uh what
the intended and unintended consequences
would be and then based upon the
findings of that I think we will be in a
position to recommend uh legislation
moving forward should we decide that
we're going to change things
so uh that is my Amendment and I would
be happy to take questions to answer to
yes thank you there is no doubt that
there is a breakdown
somewhere along the line because things
are in place
but parents are not getting the services
their children aren't getting the
services there's a breakdown somewhere
along the way and I think that studying
this
what really
bring the final result which would be of
the best interest of
the parents because this is needed
but there's a breakdown somewhat
and it's basically at the local level
and it needs to be there needs to be a
coordinated effort
to bring all this information to the
parents and to help them
to get through it it shouldn't be well
you know here's the rules you know this
is the way it goes
generic iups things like that that's
wrong
there needs to be a a distinct process
and I think that the burden of proof
should definitely be on the uh the
school district or the uh
um or the uh Doe
and not on the parents but there needs
to be more education for the parents
into their process and what they have in
front of them they shouldn't be
intimidated they shouldn't be
um expected to know all this legal stuff
and and they shouldn't have to get a
lawyer
so there's definitely a breakdown and
maybe this is the answer is is to have a
study committee
thank you
representative
okay yes go ahead I'm sorry
um
if I do want to offer the opportunity to
the paper the second who second that
motion right if you're not going to be
asking a question directly I'll
represent loan that I want to have
President Miler have a chance to think
that second decision thank you very much
representative
thank you Mr chairman I would concur
with uh president mullen's comment about
the emotion
and the issues that are with this uh
there is no doubt in my mind that uh
that parents need to have the greatest
opportunity to advocate for their child
if in fact the school they feel the
school district is uh in air as it
relates to the uh programs that the
they've uh they've proposed for their
child
but here's the issue
by the time you get to a due process
hearing it's too late
it's taken too much time
to get to that process
well perhaps some members of the
committee don't realize there is a whole
process that takes place
prior to getting to the due process
hearing there's mediation sessions
there's IEP meetings in fact in this
state we're one of the only States in
which this state the parent has to sign
off on an IEP program for their child
other states don't do that the school
district has
total control over that we don't do that
in this state we have we have taken
pride in this state
in dealing with special education needs
to students
and that process is very intimate that
moves along various ways in fact the the
disability Center has a thick book that
talks about how this is done now
my point is by the time you get to the
due process hearing it's too late for
that child
somewhere along the line
there needs to be a much more immediate
look
at how the school district and the
parents can resolve any kind of a
dispute don't forget when we had
testimony that there are not many due
because the school district wants to try
to solve these problems at the lowest
level of that process
representative Mullins Amendment
my hope would be in it if it's past is
that we could deal with those lower
level hearings to enable a more robust
sharing of information a more robust
engagement in the process so that we
don't have to get to a due process
hearing that the resolution can take
place earlier this is an important bill
for all parties involved here in my
sense the study committee would enable
us to do that we had a study committee
on this uh a session ago and we
discovered that there were many
opportunities to try to engage in this
but I think what we did Miss we missed
the opportunity of how do you share
information in a more robust way at the
earlier part of the process rather than
having to wait to a due process part to
get to that so I would encourage the
committee to seriously look at this as
an opportunity
to really open up that process and try
to resolve this
problem at the earliest phases possible
in the whole process of of considering
issues for Education special ed students
thank you very much
thank you very much representative thank
you I wanted to point out that this uh
previous Bill last term had been sent to
interim study I don't know what happened
in terms of studying but evidently there
wasn't much studying going on except
saying it should not come back to
legislation
um in terms of not many due processing
areas they're valid reasons why and
basically is the cost to the parents why
America who spent 20 30 40 000 that's
what you're testimony about to try and
do this especially when they know that
death is back against it
the school district has all the
resources uh in terms of the many steps
going up to the
um
new process here mediation and so forth
again the district holds all the parts
they have all the student information
they have the observations of the
student in the classroom
but
if they're not sharing that information
if they're not letting the parent come
in and observe the classroom if they're
not providing all the information to the
parent
the deck is stacked against them we need
to do something
proficiency levels for children with
disabilities in the state is in a
neighborhood of 15
Proficiency in math and uh English if we
want these kids with special needs to
become productive self-sufficient adults
education is the way but if they do not
get the services that they need
they're they're not going anywhere in
terms of being self-sufficient
this is a step
it's a level of flame playing field and
to give equal supporting the parents
I'll offer back to the
um letter we had from the lobbyist for
the uh school special education
administrators
unbelievable unbelievable
um
increased local costs
but what about the cost of the parents
what about the human cost what about the
cost for those children who are not
getting the services and to not get a
fair hearing and the other statement
oh yeah the school districts
um have finite costs again what about
the cost for the parents talk about
taxes anytime parents can't go out and
get a second and third job all the time
just so they can have a due process
hearing come on
a quote our president come on man let's
uh let's uh do something for the kids
let's do something for the kids with
thank you very much representative uh
representative
woodcock
thank you
representative lad I appreciate that uh
to speak to both the amendment and the
primary motion
um first off I I sincerely want to thank
representative cordelli for bringing
this topic forward
um as representative Mullen indicated uh
this is this is an easy which side of
the coin you want to be on topic there's
no right answer here uh representative
Shaw clearly indicated what the pathway
is and the the the youngsters and the
parents who are being neglected uh
Barbara's comments are right on target
it is a back loaded system when we try
to make the clarification at the final
meeting of due process the system should
be your front loaded system we engage
the youngsters and the parents the
family much earlier from day one
having sat through many IEPs throughout
my career I agree the parents often come
out short suited and this is a great
opportunity to take a look at that whole
system and and pull it together
um
so I think that's a key point I think
the this is the time to do that not wait
till the end uh I do have to uh take
numbers though with Summer
representative cordelli's comments about
leveling the playing field and the human
cost and the students cost and let's do
something that's all funding has all
education funded we want to level the
playing field let's improve the
Educational Funding system for students
and for special needs students in the
system let's improve the way we identify
access and achievement that's the whole
part of the piece you just can't extract
one little one little digit and say well
this is what we're going to address but
in the bigger picture representative
Shaw is running a Target this should be
a study committee that is robust and I'd
love to have representative cordelli on
it and I'd be happy to join them I think
this is the critical piece
parents with students who are have
special needs are Egypt from day one
it's a difficult process from day one
before the youngsters even get there and
then no matter how successful they are
which uh through the process they're
always at a disadvantage and I agree
with that but I think we have to look at
the process as a bigger entities
represent representative Ladd and start
at the bottom I I would I would be happy
to work with representative Mullen and
Cordelia on this and bring it up a
better picture better for parents thank
you
um I too have been a
teacher and a principal for the 30 years
and
absolutely I've seen so many kids
that had have had difficulties simply
because they're up against this
bureaucratic machine
and we just heard people say we need to
engage
parents are Egypt
um
not many due process hearings have been
heard I wonder why
I'll give you an example of a curve
right here with one of my own kids
grandkids
and then after
who had to have Speech Pathology
and we confer in fact my my daughter one
of my daughters is a speed pathologist
audiologist also indicated that he
needed some speech help so he went to
school we've got the IEP
when we came in for the annual review
there was real problems
our grandson told us that again really
meant was speech pathologist hardly at
all maybe once a month
and of course that's not the eye Visa
and there was a terror providing that
service
when we went in and had that IEP meeting
my daughter asked for her son is there
any documentation of those IEP meetings
which should be held she is a special ed
teacher she knows the law
there was none
no documentation of the times that the
service was supposed to be provided I
even questioned whether the service was
being provided
now this bill reverses the burden of
proof
persuasion and production are now on the
part of the school district to provide
that evidence we couldn't get the
evidence we couldn't get the schedule
book which showed the days of the days
the student didn't get their help
and and the reason why there's so very
few due process hearings
parents just don't know how to do this
or else they haven't been explained how
to do this or the leadership's not there
they're certainly not accountability
within the program I watched now I I I'm
not saying this is not a wide basis that
that's true every school it's not I I
can recall many an IEP meeting where all
that was documented the services were
provided and there was tremendous gains
so I'm not trying to squash this I don't
think that's anybody here is trying to
say and I backed up for other
administrators principles and teachers
saying yes we acknowledge there is an
issue
but I'm at the point myself where I
became a very frustrated grandfather and
in fact I frustrated father
when my son was sent out to the hallway
in a school
for a half hour unsupervised because he
was not acting appropriately in the
classroom second grade
and how he had a mural drawn all over
the hallway Paul it turned out he's
gifted
but not you well over 138 well over 138
and achievement scores and he's the one
growing rapes in Bulgaria or Romania
right now as opinion
um he made it but we were also told by
that principal in that school your son
will never graduate from high school we
were told that my wife left that IEP
mean the problem
so there are these devastating
experiences that and here I am an
administrator principal teacher and gone
through it I wonder how many others are
doing the same so I'll get over about my
soapbox here but I'm really concerned
that it's time that parents that are
like myself who have been so differently
There's an opportunity for them
to try to correct the situation but most
importantly I think that direction can't
be made right within the school where
that IEP team and the instructions being
properly supervised I don't know what
additional money is going to be the
answer for this thing
so a lot close and we'll just offer some
other folks the opportunity to speak
here uh represent Tanner I see you have
your hand up
thank you very much finally my little
paw works over there
um I want to say that uh you know this
this is a very tough situation and I
thoroughly agree with with
representative Shaw
um but I also want to amplify what
representative Woodcock said that
special ed funding uh both at the
federal level and at the state level has
been miserably underfunded and you know
local districts
um sometimes are are just sunk with with
special ed funding that's no excuse but
it certainly is part of the problem
I think when
when parents uh and schools get to the
point where they enlist lawyers and
court cases nobody wins
certainly the student hasn't won
anything at that point and sometimes
suffers greatly
so I think that the solution is not at
the end not not the let's flip the due
process procedure or let's really stick
it to the schools
um because you know they're the they're
the bad guys I think it's
um we need to look at the look at the
situation look at the the
um procedures
the oversight by the Department of
Education and really focus in on at the
beginning
where where's the issue why why is there
not more sharing of information
um obviously
um
representative Ladd chair lad you have
some definite ideas from from your
experience and I'm sure Bonnie Dunham
would have ideas and my constituents who
have talked to me have ideas and I think
we can work together to try to come up
with a system that helps the student and
doesn't put such an undue burden on both
the parents and the schools that they
get to a
place where lawyers are making money and
they're at a court case and and the
student suffers so I would strongly
recommend
um the study committee for this and
really I think you can see the passion
you can hear the passion of the people
on this committee both Democrat and
Republican and I think it's time that we
we roll our sleeves up and I think
things will get done
um
this time so that's why I would vote for
a study committee thank you
thank you very much representative
thank you
um I just want to know how long are we
going to keep studying this we studied
this the last two years we've retained
it we studied it we've had people come
in we heard stories last term we heard
stories this term
are we going to study it more are we
going to actually put some teeth in the
matter the thing that really struck me
in listening to all the testimony is
that the only person
who spoke against this spoke against it
because then parents would win more
often and the schools would have to pay
more money because they'd actually have
to provide the services that they were
supposed to and to me that's very
telling and I think if the burden of
proof was put back it was given to the
school then they might think twice about
the things that they were doing if they
had to prove that they were providing
proper support they might have kept
those records for for representative lab
um you know I they're not doing what
they're supposed to be doing right now
and so we studied we've talked we've
listened we've had parents in over and
over and over about these issues nothing
has changed I think it's time not study
it to do to actually
give the parents a little bit of power
yes there's a huge system that happens
beforehand changing burden of proof does
not change all that lead up all that
lead up is still going to be there but
but when it fails this gives the parents
a chance and it might give some
incentive to the schools to actually do
what they are supposed to do thank you
thank you see we have representative
Anderson representative
thank you Mr Speaker I'm against this
amendment because I'm also against how
much do we study something one of my
questions is and I don't think we're
going to get an answer here right now is
if this is such an issue why doesn't the
Department of Education why haven't they
stepped in and tried to straighten it
yeah
um having been a guidance counselor in a
middle school for 36 years I've seen
numerous special ed cases go through and
I I think but if you wait until the time
where it gets to the special ed hearing
and having to show burden of proof years
can have gone by
um there are so many steps to go through
before you get there that if the years
go by the student loses and the parents
lose so I think a study committee could
look at it and make put things in place
so that it doesn't get to that point if
we wait that long students would come in
in the sixth grade go through all the
steps try this try that find through off
to high school by the time it gets to
that point that's too late you know when
it should be steps incremental right at
the beginning something's wrong if
they're not getting their services right
away as they should and I think that's
what we should be looking at and I agree
with is representative Andrus that the
department of Ed should be looking at
things more closely too
thank you
representative
thank you very much Mr chairman and
representative Andrus your comments
were going to be my answer to
representative leckis
um I I I we talk all the time in this
committee about the Department of
Education not having any teeth and by
that we mean that they don't
um seem to have the supervisory capacity
to be able to step in in a situation
like this I think that's one of I I
think that's a that's a critically
important factor for us to look at in
this situation and any situation in
which we've got the department of Ed
overseeing regulatory things that go on
in schools and uh you know I I maybe
practice makes perfect maybe that's why
we're looking at this again but
um I feel like this has a different
feeling to it this time and I am hoping
against hope that we can make this into
a bipartisan effort because I'll tell
you what those kids that we're
advocating for they don't come with a
political party sticker on them so I am
hoping against hope that we are able to
seriously look at this and come up with
a well thought out solution thank you
very much
thank you
are there representative uh
got your hand up in front of your face
there we go
uh thank you Mr chairman
um I'm wondering if this is not one of
those situations in which both and is a
better answer than either or
it seems to me having heard this in
various ways for several years in my
life now that this Con final
confrontation is created of necessity by
the legal people
whereas the people trying to solve the
problem or don't have that information
going through the process
shouldn't it first be a requirement that
or any information that's placed in a
student's record on which any action is
going to be taken should be provided at
the same time to the parents
it just doesn't make any sense for the
people to hide to things or to allow
forces that don't want to spend money to
use that as a way of delaying having to
spend money
I think in this case if you pass this
bill
and you do a study committee you'll find
out what the effect is and then you can
amend that and you'll have some evidence
on which to base your decision
if you simply say oh we've got to study
and then wait exactly it's going to
happen what has happened before you'll
push it down the road
and there will be answering the same
questions again and again and again
without a solution
that's my piece I want to respond to
that representative Ford I think he's on
a track that that I would accept
that
there is Need for this to be looked at
and looked at comprehensively with the
Department of Education and with
legislative support
committee but there's also need for the
the legislation as described and put
into HB 581 to also move forward
so I I would suggest that we need to
have both
um
the for example in the situations I just
alluded to it with my own child and my
grandchild
that the proof wasn't there there was
just no documentation
and there's no way I could prove
anything
uh unless I want to go through a whole
hearing process attracting people and
I'm not that type of person I don't do
that I think many parents are the same
so we have a system that's not working
correctly I don't know and I also
support what representative Mullen has
said the fact that
most of the staff at the Department of
Education
and and R Allison whose work at the art
Department Bible is very knowledgeable
this fact that approximately 75 to 80
percent of people are coming from are
paid by federal dollars to begin with
and they're just monitoring programs
they're not actively getting out the way
they really we hope they would and to
really overseeing many of the
Departments yes some people get out
there yes they they look but it's not
the way there's no curriculum
departments and I can see now that we're
going to set up now and I I concur that
this is an area that we're really
missing in New Hampshire so
um I like the Cs move both directions if
possible
I think I think I've already said my
piece I I this is just such a such an
important issue
that I just I just think that that we
get one more shot
at this study because one of the things
I think that resume Mullins were talking
about is how do we how do we engage the
parents as part of the study
in a way so that that we can hear their
voice is loud and clear along with the
school folks so that we can get some
kind of a match here
and then come out with a recommendation
that's going to have substance to it in
a way that's not pro School Pro parents
but it's Pro kids
and I think that's the concern that I
have right now is that if we go forward
with the go as it's proposed right now
we miss that opportunity of engaging the
cheap principles that have to deal with
this issue and determining what kind of
an educational opportunity uh special
needs kids are going to have that's why
I really encourage the study thing so
that we can really look at this in a way
and come out with a recommendation
that's going to be positive and move us
forward rather than in a confrontational
mode that's my fear thank you thank you
representative so representative and I
have a question for you when you were
developing your Amendment language here
that they'll replace the your Amendment
replaces all after the enacting clause
so it basically replaces the entire Bill
and replaces it with what you have in
the amendment it does if you give any
consideration to trying to uh
incorporate both of these things that
what their men has and uh the other
which deals with the burden of proof
you know I did I I thought a lot about
it
um the reason that I went with the study
committee separate from anything to do
with the original bill is uh germane to
what representative Miler just said I
think that if we set up the adversarial
relationship between the school and the
parent prior to being able to figure out
how to work together and to give
everybody a voice and a stake in the
equation then I think we're gonna I I
think we're gonna set it up so that
people are
argumentative with each other when we
really want is for them to be
collaborative with each other
so I think that you know I I think that
I recognize the fact that this is a half
step that people who have been parent
advocates for a long time are frustrated
with I I get that
uh however I think that you know if
people can live with the half step and
we can craft a solution that does not
involve parties antagonizing each other
I think it's a win-win otherwise
I think we're right back to where we
were and that is that we end up with a
loser
turn my
um
uh in line with um this amendment uh I'd
already talked to some of the parents
who testified on the 581 about uh can
you get her this summer we're talking
about uh things that could be done
um with the entire process and where the
problems were
um so
um if the committee is willing I would
be going to have an amendment drafted to
add the study committee on qhb 581 as a
separate section of the bill
foreign
yes thank you
um
you keep talking about adversarial and
it seems to me from all the parents that
we listen to there's already if you're
going to consider adversarial
sort of this
um
almost
like they're feeling that it's
adversarial in that uh they're being
required to do all of this stuff that
they have no ability to do and
um
and so whether it's the burden of proof
on the school or burden of the proof on
the parents either way it's the burden
of proof on one of them and so if just
by having the burden of proof on one or
the other makes it adversarial it's
going to be
I don't want it to be adversarial nobody
should ever get to that point which is
the point of the study committee is to
try to see what's going on why we don't
get to that point but when we get to
that point which we urge parents who had
had all kinds of meetings and and things
that went on before they ever went to
that point
um and as I believe it was
representative
Miler said
um that there's this whole process
there's this whole process and so this
all we're talking about with this is the
end result the time when all that
process fails and at that point it
should not be the parents burden it
should be the school's birth
um
but I love the idea of the study
committee because clearly we've got to
find out why that process is failing and
try to stop it so I like the idea of
doing both give the parents something
give the parents
um an opportunity to actually
get things done when the process has
failed and try to make sure the process
Ure
if I got it yep thank you as I said
before you know when it gets to the to
the end of the line when it gets to
where this new process actually takes
place nobody's going to win uh and
nobody nobody wins and particularly the
children don't win and and the
frustration and the animosity that
exists at that point
um just isn't and frustration isn't
going to go away I mean representative
Ladd still has it from way way way back
so it's obviously a bad situation
I'm not sure
um
penalize well the flipping I I guess my
one of my problems is flipping due
process
um
that's that's a an issue that I think is
going to bring more lawyers into this
whole bill
um and and I think you know Discovery is
what we're really asking for is is is a
type of Discovery at an early stage in
the game
um and as representative Mullen said
collaboration rather than
aggravation animosity and having two
separate agencies or two separate groups
uh dig their heels in at a court case so
um I don't I I see
passing this bill as it is right now
is is going to set up more of an issue
that will be harder to resolve the
collaboration
and front loading
um work of Discovery or of sharing
documents or however we have it and so I
I don't think you need to have
you know the big Club out there
um I think what we need to do is work on
the issue and work on it in the
not seeing any uh further discussion
then
we'll go ahead and call
them
amendments
[Music]
no
representative Bell or
Representative no
Sarah Moffett nope
represent pops and
Representative no
are you muted no
no
thank you
represent way on no
representative
[Music]
yes
representative Joy yes representative
Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes
president
yes
representative way yes
[Music]
foreign
for the hot fast production option
yeah
so we now have the the bill itself
that's on the floor right now 581 Market
pass uh made by representative and
second by representative Hopson
um
to special ed funding is a problem
um I would hate to think that districts
are withholding Services because of
funding issues for these children
I think that if districts know that they
will have the burden of proven to due
process hearing maybe uh there will be
improvements uh in the process below
that in mediation Etc because the
um
districts will know that the parents
will have an important Level Playing
Field in the end and that they won't
necessarily have the upper hand and be
more willing to have a
Cooperative process all the way through
so I think that this
step in 581 in terms of burden of proof
will take a step for the parents but
also hopefully
a measure of improvement to the entire
process and I certainly want to look at
the rest of the process in the future
thank you
open for further discussion
representative
so thank you Mr chairman I just I would
just like to reiterate in a more concise
frame it's disappointing when we're
talking it turns about upper hands and
when intuitive actions when we took no
consideration uh looking for Solutions
we had an opportunity for Solutions this
is just who could who can win the prize
shame it's a shame that this type of
representative
yes I guess I I would voice uh
the same as representative Woodcock I
find it's a sad day when it seemed like
uh people were realizing and and trying
to work together in a
bipartisan manner to approach the
problem and
um it just it's gone to um punitive
action instead so
yes
and there was no prize
and there's no prize for the child no
price for my life no price for myself no
price for the school because the school
didn't achieve what they said they were
going to achieve
so I I I'm sad that we were unable to
mail these bills together because I
think there is reason for it as the idea
was brought forth by uh representative
Ford and I think that's a good proposal
that we needed to have both going on
here but we can't afford to lose kids
for another year while we talk about
this thing
and this stuff's happening and it's
impossible for the parents to oftentimes
to get a hold of the facts
the evidence which is necessary for them
to go forward for the hearing and so
right now
it's a death it's not stacked on behalf
of the parent that it saddens me that
that's the way it is and if this is the
way it occurs and has to happen
yes thank you and in my years as a
teacher and and listening to the phone
calls and reading the emails that I
received from constituents who have had
experience with uh special needs uh IEPs
with the school districts
I I feel strongly that the burden of
group should lie on the schools and and
should have been done
years ago it shouldn't be to parents
that have to get a lawyer to defend for
their child
it should be the school district to have
to present the proof
and I think that there is like I said
before there is a strong breakdown and I
think that it's important that we study
it
and I'm hoping that if this passes out
of committee that a poor Amendment will
come forward on the house floor that
will combine these two
and or that will add to HB 581 so that
the uh the uh study committee can be
incorporated into this because
there needs to be a study of the process
and if this passes it'll be more even
more of an incentive for a study
committee to get on the ball and come up
with some concrete answers and some
things that can help parents in this
frustrating process
thank you thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman
it seems like there seems it appears
their support for this idea
put forward by representative Ford
of both the bill and a study
I'm just wondering I mean we're going to
continue with the exec session next week
we've already received notice of it
there's nothing that requires us to
finalize our action on 581 at this
moment
we could easily draw up
the requisite Amendment as suggested by
representative Ford
um and amend the amend 581 next week and
then act upon it on Tuesday because the
notice is already gone out I I noticed
it in my email of continued executive
session
the Bill's posted today but that does
not require that we complete action on
it's just a suggestion
that's what I was alluding to when I
spoke earlier not the last time but
prior to that that I see potential for
working towards getting inclusion of
both of these principles into some kind
of legislation and
I think this is too big an issue to
not really
try to achieve what we all recognize
needs to be done
so I'm open to
recessing this for about a week until
weekend you know maybe come up with some
amending language we may be able to we
may not but at least we've given it that
shot
I would support that
Senate uh
representative yeah thank you
uh earlier I had said I would be wanting
to uh bring forward a minute but
combining us
[Music]
if there is support on the committee for
uh 581 bus schedule committing uh then I
would be willing to withdraw my motion
uh for today and we can continue it uh
next week with an amendment we just have
to recessive
that you don't have to do that we just
can recess if we can come back okay
if I'd like to see if that's a general
feeling of the book here that would like
to work you know maybe you would
represent for daily or representative
cordelli working with a group by
Healthcare which way to go so I just
but uh could I could I suggest uh Mr
chair that perhaps uh representative
cordelli and representing Mullen
uh get together and representative Ford
to try to craft something that can
combine the respective issues that have
been presented in this particular
hearing could that be done that can be
done
who would do it so yeah uh I think that
can happen and everybody's okay with
that if I don't hear anybody saying
anything contrary then we'll recess this
until a time next week
put it on one of the exact sessions
which we have set up
very good thank you objections that's
what we'll do thank you so much
everybody
[Music]
um
quick weekend here keep marching down
here uh the next one on the dock is cacr
three
or we can jump over that and take that
on the following week and jump to let's
say 455. what's the weather today
relative to the ability of a parent to
enroll a child in a public school of
I'd like to represent recognize
representative for a motion
all right this uh the hearing on 1845 at
uh quite a bit of uh discussion
um and uh I think that there are uh
things that
um
motion first I guess right yes I'm
willing to retain 1845 right the 455.
representative Andrews do you have a
second I second the motion thank you
very much
[Music]
there was a lot of discussion and I
think there were some points raised and
I know that there were already things
that I would like to look at
um in terms of this legislation in
relation to what other states have done
um that have open enrollment policies
and legislation on the books
um so that is why I would like to uh
I concur with uh
by Shaman codelli and because I think
there's a lot of work we could do on
this bill and improve it and bring it
back
thank you the bill is now before
discussion representative
uh thank you Mr chair and I want to I
want to thank the sponsor of the bill
representative cordelli for retaining
this bill
this is this proposal is a major change
in
um how in a school choice option here
and it it
if we're going to have a bill like this
we need to make sure that it represents
the experience
of other states that have similar bills
I've studied the bill in in
Massachusetts
and the current bill before us is sorely
lacking
any of the experience that they've had
in the past 25 years in Massachusetts
regarding this bill and I know there are
other states that have done similar too
so I think my point being is that if
you're going to have a school choice
bill
it needs to be representative of those
that have gone through the tong Wars of
uh implementing such a such a change in
in a school choice option that I think
will give us an opportunity to look at
those sense of experiences and at least
come forward with a bill that is
complete and can represent that sense of
experience I may not support the bill
but I want to make sure that the bill at
least is going to be
solid in experience from other states
so I thank representative cordelli for
putting this uh retention Bill forward
because I think it's needed and I
frankly look forward to looking to
working on this Bill thank you thank you
very much representative representative
uh
yeah I um was fortunate enough
to end up sitting next to a lady from
Michigan on an airplane and we had a
long conversation the whole way out
um about what Michigan has passed this
years ago and what the effects on their
school were and everything and so I
think this is a great
um idea to retain this and look at it
and talk to other states who've been
through this who know what are what were
the immediate consequences what are the
long-term consequences and I think it's
thank you Mr chair
um this comment is actually for
representative cordelli uh
I don't know if you remember
representative cordelli but the last
time we talked about this during the
hearing I mentioned the fact that we
have a tuition program in Bedford uh I
went a little a little deeper to see
what kind of status were at at this
point and according to the district uh
information we currently don't have
available seats in the middle school or
the high school uh but there's an
application process for the elementary
school and the tuition is 14 200 per
student
so I just wanted to bring that to your
attention because we were talking about
that tuition aspect and the fact that a
community like Bedford that already has
a tuition program would lose fourteen
thousand two hundred dollars per student
uh if in fact this bill were to go
forward without uh any kind of awareness
of that
I don't see any further comments here
um
please go ahead and follow your goal and
emotions for retention of HP 455
relatively American Girl child in the
public schools of their choice
representative cordelli yeah
representative phone yes representative
Allard an enthusiastic yes
representative leikis yes representative
Moffett Federal enthusiastic yes
preparator Hobson yes representative
represent Tanner yes represent Ellison
done
okay we're going to now uh I'm going to
try to get us out of here several people
have indicated they have to be leaving
by around 2 15.
and so I'm going to try to get another
bill done here
um
HP 323
is relative to the Statewide student
okay we'll open up the hearing on House
Bill 323 relative Statewide students who
support and then I'll call on Sherman
lab to introduce the bill
um
at least there are seconds to that
motion
um
thank you
Mr chairman would like to speak to your
emotions yeah it's just so everybody can
recall
what this bill was about is to remember
that it was when the student assessment
the results from the Statewide
assessment we're forwarded to parents by
a date and the date was June uh June
30th at the end of the fiscal year but
since then we've also retained another
or not retained but a bill has to move
forward uh 194 release of assessment
information that assessment information
was the one that the the Department of
Education has been directed to work with
the testing agency and for the agency to
send student results directly to the
parent
I'm hoping that if that still didn't
succeeds then perhaps we don't need this
bill however I'm asking to retain it in
case that bill does not move forward or
if it moves forward maybe the testing
agency also has to be told that the
testing results are sent to the parent
by June 30th so we've heard from the
testing from the Department of Education
from the commissioner that testing
results are available to the schools
immediately upon the students completing
that test
so it's all online so um so I'm asking
that we do retain this and watch what's
going on with 194. thank you Mr chair
thank you
um
does anyone else having uh comments on
president Poland
thank you Mr chair
um my only comment is that when we heard
testimony on this bill last time around
we had a number of school districts come
in and give us specific reasons for why
they were holding off on sharing the
test results until September
namely that they were sharing them at
the beginning of a school year setting
academic goals with kids and parents and
moving forward from there so
um I would just ask that at some point
in time we consider whether or not there
is any wiggle room at all in this to
allow schools the local control aspect
of utilizing the test reports at a time
for a reason I'm not talking about
negligence or you know not getting
around to sending them home I'm talking
about those districts that came in and
said we hold them because we don't want
parents to uh
get information that they don't have
staff to bounce ideas off of and we use
them for academic goals in the fall
thank you
representative cordelli yes
this is to retain HB 323 representative
ball yes representative yes
representative yes representative yes
representative Hopson
Senator Andrews yes representative Ford
yes
[Music]
I'm looking out the window here on the
third floor and the sun is out what an
engagement site uh I think what I'm
going to do is I'm going to post the
executive sessions for today down all
right basically close to two o'clock and
we'll come back and address uh other
bills which we have we're narrowing down
we're getting to the list we have uh
next week uh Tuesdays Tuesday and
Thursday schedule and there's even a
possibility of working at the following
one so
um it looks like we're going to get our
job done
um I'm going to go out and try to get
some fun in the sun so with that uh Rick
before you go I just wanna I wanna if I
may
can we just go down where the reports
that you're expecting so we can clarify
that for everyone well for today yeah
yeah I I've got if you if you may I've
got a report from now on Tuesday on 278
yeah
okay our
I'll spell uh 278
is that all you need to know
um
then the next the next one is what 140.
yeah no no I mean I'll read them but you
want to know who's doing the majority as
well yeah yeah we might as well yes
right yeah all right I was built 278
majority report for Ellie
uh representative I'm saying it once
representative
uh cordelli and Cornell House Bill 140
Leon and Muno
uh representative I mean House Bill 422
Moffitt
Dallas Bill 267 Austin
[Music]
house bill
very good 581 with recess
455 retain
323 retain
and 441 uh me I didn't write it yet okay
thank you for 41 was IPL IPL and now you
already sent the report yeah
[Music]
okay so we went to one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten ten exact
language
we need to have those reports the way it
works if you should send
the email attachment to myself you can
also send them to Gen 4 but I have to
look at them and read them then they go
to Jen she looks at them for you know
grammatical stuff and all that again
then they go to uh Lindsay Force here
who's our Administrative Assistant not
Judy this year Lindsay and from there
they go over to Paul Smith he gets them
and then he goes takes them to the
speaker and the speaker approves our
District closed and then then they're
put in the calendar so it's quite a
process so I'd like to see those reports
come and as soon as you have them email
me a copy email Jenna copy that makes
hey Rick yes yeah on the um on the work
groups the the merger work group that's
going to begin tomorrow
do you have a you you started out this
meeting talking about the next several
meetings and concluding its work um
on the uh I guess two weeks from
tomorrow
um I was wondering do you have a um is
there like a a rough agenda item on
people we're going to be hearing from it
sounded like that had been uh worked out
and I was just wondering if if you had a
copy of that it's pretty much confirmed
I just have to get on the horn after
this and talk to both Susan which uh
Sharon said she was taught Shannon said
she was going to talk to uh Susan and
she basically said yes yesterday to me
and the other one is Don Burks and
Catherine provencher basically said yes
to me that Don would and I spoke to Don
about a week ago other than that
um everybody is confirmed
um so
um I will get the agenda out to folks um
when I get home this this evening you
know that'd be great and and tomorrow
morning we've got with who's who's
coming to
um talk with us about sort of questions
and considerations
right
it's uh Ed McKay oh I'm sorry okay good
okay
you used to be the university system of
New Hampshire president
Ed is going to come in and provide us
his understandings and some of those
issues that we will might or might not
encounter in mergers
and give us his background and
information regarding that he's also
going to be working a little bit later
on on Monday with the finance dealing
with the audit that came back on the
unique program the 529 program
thank you the other thing I might I
might suggest to Rick since since we
have this resource in state and and
she's been a tremendous
um resource to the community colleges
um is um is Dr Catherine Addy who I
she was formerly with the Connecticut
um community college system and I know
that's subject of the um of the enchems
I spoke with uh Shannon
either yesterday before it's all mixing
together here I asked okay we're very
limited with time
who might be the best person to try
that's been a practitioner at being a
president professor and all that and she
basically said without even hesitating
oh no question about that yeah well
there's no question about that I was
just saying somebody that that had their
feet on the ground in Connecticut which
is one of the three examples
um merger I I think we might get some of
that information provided us uh from
Barbara uh brittenham who's going to be
coming up on Messi on on uh the
following flight okay great great work
with issues like this so if we see that
we would like that there's a possibility
we could invite somebody else in on
Friday
we're gonna have to use some of that
time to try and put something together I
hope it's not a party
great great well look forward to seeing
that uh that agenda anyway because I
think that will help to sort of weigh
out the
um
okay with that uh we're gonna close down
this executive session I wish everybody
to have a good weekend if we don't see
you on on Friday
thanks Rick thank you thanks Rick you're
welcome